Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Zu Malen nach Zahlen hier im Blue Moon. Auf Ritz jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat geht es im Chaos Radio um Dinge, die sich rund um das digitale Leben und dessen, sagen wir mal, kreativer Verwendung drehen. Heute wieder reichhaltig Menschen zu Gast, die mich schon völlig durcheinander gebracht haben, aber das gehört ja auch zum guten Ton, das heißt ja nicht umsonst Chaos Radio. Und unter anderem mit dabei ein Herr Erdgeist. Ein Herr Nibbler. Hallo. Und ein Herr Linus. Und wir machen heute, ja, das freut mich also ganz besonders, weil das Chaos Radio ist ja immer, also der Chaos Computer Club kommt her und die erzählen dann irgendwas, das ist halt irgendwie so digital, netzpolitisch, security, science fiction, irgendwas. Aber heute passiert tatsächlich etwas ganz Neues. Also es ist Folge 192 und heute passiert etwas, was glaube ich in der Geschichte des Chaos Radios und möglicherweise sogar in der Geschichte des Chaos Computer Clubs so noch nie passiert ist. Die hier anwesenden Herren des Chaos Computer Clubs machen heute genau das, was der Innenminister sagt.
Verschlüsselungstechniken, Virenabwehrprogramme, all diese Fragen müssen noch mehr in den Fokus gerückt werden. Die Menschen müssen sich bewusst werden, dass Kommunikation im Netz auch einen Schutzbedarf. Und auch das ist eine Diskussion, die wir vorantreiben werden.
Ja, vielleicht habt ihr in den letzten Wochen nicht ganz in der Höhle gelebt und mitbekommen, dass es da so ein kleiner Überwachungsskandal gab, wo halt rausgekommen ist, dass quasi unsere Internetüberwachung total überwacht wird und dass dann unsere Politiker, also insbesondere die, die möglicherweise dafür verantwortlich sein sollten, unsere Privatfähre zu schützen, gesagt haben, ja, das könnt ihr doch bitte auch mal selber machen, ja, verschlüsselt doch mal.
Hört sich faszinierend an. Es ist ungefähr wie den Leuten zu erzählen, ja, macht irgendwie eure Häuser doch mal so sicher, macht wie Bunker draus, weil Polizei ist eigentlich keine staatliche Aufgabe mehr. Wir haben da jetzt mal aufgegeben gegen ausländische Spitze und haben das der Bevölkerung mal geoutzhorst.
Genau, das könnt ihr euch gefällig selber kümmern. Und wir wollen gleich dazu sagen, das geht natürlich so eigentlich nicht. Es ist auch totaler Quatsch, dass man sich mit Virenscannern vor dem Abschnorcheln von Kommunikation, die durchs Netz läuft, schützen kann. Aber wir wollen trotzdem heute, weil es ja im Zuge dieses ganzen Überwachungsskandals auch zu sogenannten Cryptopartys gekommen ist, heute mal hier im Chaosradio zwei Stunden lang damit beschäftigen, wie man eigentlich Verschlüsselungen verstehen und auch für Anfänger anwenden kann. Das heißt, heute ist wichtiger als sonst, falls irgendwo an einem Punkt ein Verständnisproblem auftritt. Und ihr denkt, ja, also eigentlich hätte ich das jetzt noch verstehen können, wenn ihr es nur ein bisschen besser erklärt habt, dann könnt ihr gerne anrufen 0331 77 97 110. Ansonsten haben die drei Herren sich tatsächlich so eine Art Plan ausgedacht für die Sendung. Auch das eine absolute Neuigkeit hier im Chaosradio.
Du solltest das nicht verraten.
Setz uns nicht unter Druck.
Ich will trotzdem kurz erklären, was sie sich ausgedacht haben. Und zwar ist ja diese ganze Sache mit der Verschlüsselung. Da gibt es ja verschiedene Dinge, die man verschlüsseln kann. Deswegen fangen wir am Anfang erstmal ganz abstrakt an und klären erstmal, was heißt denn das überhaupt? Also was heißt denn, was bedeutet es, wenn man Kommunikation verschlüsselt? Und dann wird das in einzelnen Anwendungsfällen erklärt und das abgestuft in, könnt ihr auch euren Eltern installieren?
Nee, nee, nee, müsst ihr euren Eltern installieren. Sonst seid ihr reiben Rabenkinder.
Ah, genau so war es.
Aber sind Rabenkinder nicht von Raben?
Nee, das sind Rabeneltern.
Achso, aber Rabenkinder, ja. Also wenn der quasi die Taub hat durch die...
Wann hast du eigentlich das letzte Mal deiner Mama ihren Computer gepflegt?
Wisst ihr, warum ich hier bin, Leute? Warum ich hier bin, das ist, damit in den zwei Stunden die Leute nicht völlig irgendwie so die Spur verlieren und sich auf einmal über Ornithologie unterhalten, sondern damit wir immer schön beim Thema bleiben. Also lieg uns um es für dich zu übersetzen, ja? Du wärst ein böser Junge.
Der Lipp von meiner Mama ist aber länger als der Kie von Erdgeistesmama.
Deine Mama tanzt zu meinem Klingelton, Alter.
Ja, wir machen heute hier quasi Bildungsradio, wie ihr schon hört. Also das ist alles total gut. Nachdem wir sozusagen geklärt haben, was man seinen Eltern installiert haben muss, wenn man sich nicht streflicher Nachlässigkeit schuldig machen will, erklären wir, was ihr ausprobieren könnt, wenn ihr euch selber so ein bisschen abenteuerlich fühlt. Also die Grundlagen, was wirklich einfach funktioniert, was man wirklich einfach machen sollte, das klären wir sozusagen für die Eltern. Aber dieses so, okay, ihr habt Bock, euch mal ein kleines bisschen mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen, ein kleines bisschen Zeit und Grips zu investieren, das ist das. Und dann ganz zum Schluss kommen wir zu dem Punkt, den ich mir erlaubt habe zu titillieren, wir basteln uns einen Aluhut. Also Verschlüsselung und Schutz für Fortgeschrittenen.
Na wenn alle Geheimdienste der Welt hinter dir her sind, du musst ganz dringend die geleakten Dokumente, die du gerade mitgenommen hast bei dem großen Verteidigungscontractor, den auf deiner Festplatte verschlüsseln und du willst, dass selbst mit den größten Rechenzentren der Welt sie deinen Schlüssel, deine Verschlüsselung nicht knacken können, dann ist dann am Ende das schon so kompliziert, dass man seinen Eltern das nicht mehr antun möchte. Aber in die Richtung muss man natürlich mal weiter denken. In 15 Jahren ist es wahrscheinlich auch Standard.
Das machen wir zum Schluss. Und dann klären wir noch, was Verschlüsselung, also im Rahmen dieser Überwachung überhaupt kann. Und wo man vielleicht noch sagen muss, das ist ein Problem, das können wir nicht dadurch klären, dass wir selber verschlüsseln, auch wenn unser Innenminister das gerne hätte, sondern möglicherweise gibt es da noch die ein oder andere politische oder gesellschaftliche Säule, die man sozusagen zum Schutz und zur Stütze brauchen könnte.
Und ansonsten geht wie immer bei Fragen, Fragen.
Genau, wir haben da sogar etwas vorbereitet, auch das eine völlige Neuigkeit.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110.
Wobei es natürlich schon wieder falsch war, ihr müsst nicht jetzt anrufen, sondern ihr sollt dann anrufen, wenn ihr eine Verständnisfrage habt. Oder, und dazu kommen wir jetzt, wenn ihr eine total gute Idee habt, wie man Verschlüsselung erklären kann, jemand dem es noch nie erklärt wurde. Wir versuchen das jetzt hier, aber meiner Meinung nach ist da sozusagen der goldene Zweig, die eierlegende Wollmilchsau noch nicht gefunden worden. Das heißt, wenn ihr da irgendwie eine Idee habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. Wir hören jetzt erstmal an, was die drei Herren hier zu sagen haben. So, die Herren Linus, Nibbler, Erdgeist, was zur Hölle ist denn eigentlich Verschlüsselung und warum hilft es uns gegen so eine Sachen wie Prison, Tempora, X-Key-Score und was es sonst noch einen schönen Überwachungsprogramm gibt?
Hm, also Verschlüsselung ist erstmal ein ziemlich großer Begriff, der für diverse Dinge benutzt wird, die eigentliche erstmal wenig miteinander zu tun haben. Aber grundsätzlich geht es bei der Verschlüsselung darum, irgendwelche nicht realen Dinge, also Daten, vor dem unbefugten Zugriff anderer zu entziehen. Und da gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten, diese Nachrichten, zum Beispiel, während sie in einem Brief von mir an dich drin stehen, so zu modifizieren, dass es für irgendjemanden, der unseren Schlüssel nicht kennt, unmöglich ist, den Inhalt der Nachricht in Erfahrung zu bringen. Das ist grob Verschlüsselung. Es gibt aber in diesem ganzen Themenbereich der Kryptographie noch andere Werkzeuge, weil man ja nicht nur ein Interesse daran hat, dass die Nachricht unterwegs nicht mitgelesen werden kann, sondern man hat auch ein Interesse daran, dass die Nachricht unterwegs nicht von jemandem Bösem modifiziert werden kann. Also gibt es andere Werkzeuge, die neben der Vertraulichkeit der Nachricht auch noch die Integrität der Nachricht bestätigen kann, wo andere kryptografische Mechanismen gebraucht werden. Und ferner gibt es noch... Halt! Nein, das ist nur für die Übersicht. Der letzte Punkt ist noch die Authentizität, dass du sicher sein kannst, dass die Nachricht von mir kommt.
Und dass eben darüber hinaus, dass die Nachricht nur von Erdgeiss E-Mail-Adresse kommt. Also wenn Erdgeiss mir jetzt so eine E-Mail schreibt, dann ist das übliche Verband, dass ich deshalb davon ausgehe, dass sie von Erdgeiss kommt, weil sie von seiner E-Mail-Adresse kommt.
Das ist aber genauso sicher, wie als wenn du einen Brief mit deinem Briefkasten findest und dort steht der Absender. Und der Absender ist Erdgeist, und deswegen glaubst du, dass dieser Brief zwingend von mir sein muss. Das ist ja natürlich auch nicht gegeben, weil jeder das da draußen draufschreiben kann und dann irgendwo in den Briefkasten werfen. Und daher ist ein drittes Werkzeug eben die Authentizität, die man mit Signaturen erreichen kann, dass dein Empfänger nachvollziehen kann, ob das wirklich von dir ist.
Der erste Teil, das war, dass die Nachricht nur von den Leuten gelesen werden kann, die den Schlüssel dazu haben.
Heißt Vertraulichkeit.
Der zweite Teil ist, dass die Nachricht von jemandem verändert werden kann.
Das ist Integrität.
Und nicht verändert werden kann.
Genau.
Dritte ist, dass die Nachricht auch von demjenigen kommt, von dem drauf steht, dass sie kommt.
Und das ist Authentizität.
Okay, also ich glaube gerade die Integrität, da hab ich kurz gestockt, weil das ist also der Punkt, dass man sagt, die Nachricht, die bei jemanden ankommt, ist genau dieselbe, die losgeschickt wurde.
Genau, und das beweise ich dann durch ein kompliziertes mathematisches Verfahren, wo eigentlich am wichtigsten ist, dass man versteht, was die Eigenschaften dieses Verfahrens sind und nur für Fortgeschrittene dann mal nachzugucken, wie dieses Verfahren funktioniert. Aber Fortgeschrittene, das heutzutage, das sind, naja, mit Schulbuch-Mathematik kann man viel von dem, was bei der Implementation moderner Cryptographie benutzt wird, kriegt man schon noch nachvollzogen und kann auch verstehen, warum es sicher ist.
Ich möchte noch ein bisschen was zu einer Randbedingung sagen. Also wir werden heute relativ wenig Zeit darauf verwenden, zu argumentieren, ob man überhaupt verschlüsseln sollte. Falls ihr euch das noch fragt...
Was muss man da argumentieren?
Da musst du dir die Tagesthemen heute gucken.
Na ja, man kann doch einfach das letzte Chaosradio anhören. Chaosradio 191, da ging es um die großen Brüder, wurde genau erklärt, was da so alles möglich ist. Ansonsten einfach mal Nachrichten checken, also um die Argumentation scheren wir uns nicht und vielleicht auch noch den Namen erklären. Cryptoparty, wenn euch das heute irgendwie total interessant vorkommt, aber ihr noch mehr Input braucht, es gibt diese Veranstaltung. Die heißen wirklich Cryptopartys und wir sind dafür da, um genau so eine Sache zu erklären. Wir versuchen das heute sozusagen in einem Radioformat nachzufeiern. So, jetzt wissen wir also grob, was Verschlüsselung ist.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir aber leider noch mal darauf hinweisen, du hattest jetzt nämlich gerade Prism und Tempora angesprochen, dass dabei ja leider nicht nur die inhaltlichen Daten mitgeschnitten worden sind, sondern dass leider in Kommunikation noch ziemlich viel Verkehrsdaten anfallen. Also sämtliche Metadaten zu welcher Uhrzeit, von welcher E-Mail-Adresse an welche E-Mail-Adresse, vielleicht sogar in Reaktionen, auf was eine E-Mail losgeschickt worden ist. Diese Informationen fallen auch an. Und mit den Standard-Kryptographischen Werkzeugen ist dem nicht beizukommen. Da braucht man dann Anonymisierungswerkzeuge, wie zum Beispiel Tor oder Jab. Die haben wir aber schon in anderen Sendungen ziemlich ergiebig besprochen.
Kommen wir nachher noch mal kurz zu, aber wichtig ist halt zu wissen, es wird heute zum größeren Teil der Zeit darum gehen, Inhalte zu verschlüsseln. Und dass man aber trotzdem genau beobachten kann, wer hat wann mit wem geredet. Und in manchen Fällen kann man sogar noch sehen, worüber haben die geredet. Also sozusagen die Überschrift, den Betreff einer E-Mail. Wir können uns heute nicht um alles kümmern.
Vielleicht sei aber noch wirklich der Hinweis angebracht, dass dieses Metadaten sammeln, also wer hat wann mit wem geschrieben, dann doch auch eine, vielleicht sogar die größere und nicht zu unterschätzende Gefahr ist.
Das ist längerfristig, weil in UK, also in Großbritannien, gibt es den Ansatz Take All, also sprich erstmal alle Daten sammeln und speichern. Und das wird dann über die Zeit ausgedünnt. Das heißt, den vollen Internetverkehr erhebt man sich für zwei, drei Tage auf und dann wird da immer weiter rausgeworfen. Und am Ende ist das einzige, was man wirklich gerne aufhebt, weil es wenig Daten sind und weil es viel bringt, eben genau diese Metadaten. Das ist nur ein Bruchteil von der gesamten Information, die sie da abschnorcheln. Aber das ist der Teil der Information, der am aussagekräftigsten ist über persönliche Netzwerke, wer mit wem, wann, von wo nach wo kommuniziert. Und da kann man sich auch Dinge wie Informationshierarchien rausbilden, also wie eine Organisation funktioniert anhand der Kommunikationsbeziehungen.
Also du hast vor allem die Analyseverfahren dafür. Das Datenniveau ist so, dass es einfach sehr angenehm ist, das zu analysieren.
Das ist auch ein wohlverstandenes mathematisches Problem, Grafentheorie und so weiter.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht gleich anfangen, die Leute.
Dazu jetzt an dieser Stelle zwei Fragen. Also erst mal noch der Versuch einer Zusammenfassung. Das ist der, über die Metadaten lässt sich dann rausfinden. Ich weiß dann zwar nicht, was gesagt wurde, aber ich weiß schon mal, wem ich auf die Füße treten muss, um zu erfahren, was er gesagt hat. Aber, und das wäre jetzt natürlich die kacke Gegenfrage, wenn das mit den Metadaten so schlimm ist, warum muss ich denn überhaupt noch verschlüsseln?
Das schließt deine Kürbe doch zu Hause auch ab, wenn du dein Haus verlässt oder lässt du das offen?
Also es ist schon mal besser als nichts. Es ist ein, du hast natürlich, wenn du dir bewusst bist, dass da Metadaten anfallen, kannst du oder musst du dann dein Kommunikationsverhalten in bestimmten Fällen auch verändern. Aber das ist eigentlich ein autogonales Problem und das ist auch anzugehen, aber darum geht es heute nicht. Wir wollen ja heute eigentlich Kryptographie den Inhalt verschlüsseln und da ist natürlich der Inhalt, wenn man sich dann mal ein Ziel ausgesucht hat und den Inhalt entschlüsseln kann, hat man natürlich noch ein viel detaillierteres Bild. Also diese Metadaten geben einem nur ungefähr vor, wem man auf die Füße treten muss und wo man versuchen muss, vielleicht auf besondere Kommunikationen noch mal besonders scharf draufzuschauen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass man deswegen alle Kommunikationen, die man normalerweise per Brief versenden würde, dann auch auf die Postkarte draufschreibt.
Aber das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, auch sozusagen einer dieser grundlegenden Ansätze, dieser ganzen Verschlüsselungsbildung, die jetzt auch stattfindet. Dass man halt sagt, ja, es ist ja auch so ein Argument, ich hab nichts zu verbergen. Oder manche Leute sagen auch, ich verschlüssel nur, wenn es total irgendwie wichtig ist. Aber das macht ja auch wieder aufmerksam. Und die Idee ist, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, dass man sagt, naja, es wäre gut, wenn Verschlüsselung zu so einem Standard wäre. Also, im Standardverhalten, dann ist jeden User so was, wie halt eben Wohnungszüge abschließen oder im Auto anstallen oder so.
Ich finde einfach, es sind zwei unterschiedliche Probleme. Und das eine muss auch gelöst werden. Aber es heißt nicht, dass man das andere nicht angehen soll. Also, wie gesagt, man schreibt ja auch nicht nur Postkarten, wenn man dort an seine Liebste einen längeren Brief schreibt. Da will man nicht, dass da alle Postboten, jeder im Dorf drauf gucken kann. Sondern tut es in dem Brief, auch wenn es dann am Ende ein Liebesbrief...
Was ich gerade versucht habe zu sagen, ist sozusagen, dass ich meine Verstanden zu haben, dass der Ansatz ist, wir sollten alle immer unsere kommunikationen Briefumschläge stecken. Genau. Als Standardverhalten.
Obwohl, das hat auch den Vorteil, dass in dem Moment, wo jemand wirklich was zu verbergen hat, wie beispielsweise Herr Snowden, dass nicht unnormal ist, dass er verschlüsselt. Weil, wenn nur die Leute verschlüsseln, die vielleicht Dinge mitzuteilen haben, die jetzt wichtig sind.
Dann fallen die auf?
Dann fallen die auf.
Also erstmal ein Grundrauschen erzeugen. Dass du, wenn du verschlüsselst, gehst du einfach im Rauschen der anderen verschlüsselten Kommunikation in der Welt einfach unter. Und dann fällt das nicht auf.
So, das ist jetzt die grundlegende Motivation und die grundlegende Erklärung für Verschlüsselung. Es wird im Folgenden in der Erklärung wahrscheinlich in einem großen Teil um E-Mail-Verschlüsselung gehen. Und dann fragt ihr euch vielleicht, E-Mail benutzt doch eh keiner mehr, völlig alt, ne ne ne. Das trifft zum Teil zu, aber wenn wir über andere Verschlüsselungen reden, dann kommen immer dieselben Techniken zum Einsatz, mehr oder weniger. Das heißt, man kann, selbst wenn man keine E-Mails mehr schreibt, daran schon mal sehr gut verstehen, wie Verschlüsselung funktioniert.
Verschlüsselung ist ja auch nicht an E-Mail gebunden. Also was wir jetzt als E-Mail-Verschlüsselung behandeln, kann ich genauso gut durch eine Facebook-Nachricht schieben oder durch eine SMS oder was auch immer ich dann als Kanal wähle.
Instant Messaging zum Beispiel.
Wie auch immer. Das Gleiche nutze ich auch gerne zum Verschlüsseln von Dateien auf meiner Festplatte. Es geht einfach darum, genau, oder bei dieser ganzen Verschlüsselungssache darum, dem Kanal, über den man sich austauscht, eben nicht zu vertrauen. Und da gibt es ja einfach die Anzahl an Kanälen, denen man nicht vertrauen kann, ist eben unendlich. Und über all diese kann man dann auch...
Hast du gerade gesagt, wir werden beobachtet?
Ich hab nur gesagt, dass ich keinen, wir haben da nur...
Hat der Herr Pofalla heute nicht gesagt, dass wir nicht alle beobachtet werden?
Ach, eher nicht, hat er kein Internet.
Der war doch jetzt im Urlaub, da hatte der kein Internet. Sieben Wochen Urlaub hatte der Mann. Und jetzt wird er brutalst möglich aufklären, das wird spannend.
Eine direkte Lüge oder einfach Unfälligkeit, und ich weiß nicht, was von beiden besser ist, weil natürlich wird der Datenverkehr mitgelesen, wenn er unverschlüsselt ist. Das ist einfach viel zu einfach.
Wieso sagst du das, dass sich das gegenseitig ausschließt?
Unfähigkeit.
Du böser, böser Mann. Fangen wir jetzt mit den Eltern-Sachen an, oder wollt ihr noch mal Verschlüsselung genauer erklären?
Wir können da mal versuchen, die Werkzeuge, die man so für Kryptographie braucht, noch ein bisschen zu erklären. Da hat natürlich jeder einen anderen Ansatz, weil, wie ich schon sagte, das ist echt verdammt viel Mathematik. Aber auf der anderen Seite sind die Grundkonzepte gar nicht so schwer nachzuvollziehen.
Na dann mal los.
Kryptographie ist ja eigentlich schon ziemlich alt. Informationen ist in Zeiten des Krieges total nützlich gewesen, welche Armee an welcher Stelle wo steht und wie angreift. Das wollte man ja so einem Läufer, wenn man dem das in die Hand drückt, weiß man halt nicht, ob man diesem Läufer da jetzt vertrauen kann oder ob der unterwegs von einer feindlichen Patrouille weggeschnappt wird. Oder bezahlt.
Oder gar die Nachricht auf dem Weg geändert wird, wo wir bei der Integrität sind.
Genau, sodass schon ziemlich früh angefangen wurde, durch Geheimschriften, durch große Codebücher, Nachrichten durch verschlüsselte Versionen zu ersetzen, dass man eben dieses Codebuch, also den Schlüssel, braucht, um diese Nachricht wieder zurück zu übersetzen. Das hat sich im Laufe der Zeit viel verfeinert, weil sich für jeden, der so Cryptografie braucht, ein neues Schiffrierverfahren auszudenken. Weil wenn es einmal in der Hand des Gegners ist, so ein Codebuch zum Beispiel, dann ist das total unpraktisch, weil da muss man ein neues Codebuch schreiben. Oder wenn das Verfahren geheim gehalten worden ist und irgendjemand kommt jetzt durch intensive Analyse darauf, wie dieses Verfahren funktioniert, und kann dann rückwirkend Nachrichten wieder entschlüsseln, ist nicht besonders praktisch. Und irgendwann kam dann mein Mathematiker darauf, dass man bestimmte Eigenschaften von so Funktionen benutzen kann, um eine Nachricht mit diese Funktion reinzugeben, einfach einen ganz langen numerischen Schlüssel zu nehmen, die damit zu verwursten, und dann kommt eine andere Zahl draus. Und diese Zahl kann dann durch das Internet geschickt werden. Und auf der anderen Seite macht man dieselbe mathematische Operation mit demselben Schlüssel und kommt dann wieder auf das Original. Und das mit dem Computer ist es total praktisch, weil so große Zahlen ist halt genau das, womit ein Computer den ganzen Tag zu tun hat. So die ganze Speicher ist ja nichts weiter als Zahlen. Und man konnte also anfangen, das so weit zu abstrahieren, dass das Verfahren, eins von vielen Verfahren aktuell, das ist journalisierte, das heißt AES, macht mit einem bestimmten Schlüssel, den man da rein gibt, auf den man sich auf irgendeine Art und Weise dann einigen muss mit der Gegenseite, kann man also Klartext so verwürfeln, dass es unterwegs, zum Beispiel über ein unsicheres Netz, nur noch wie Rauschen aussieht, und auf der anderen Seite dieses Rauschen wieder genauso generiert werden kann, um dann den Klartext zurückzurechnen.
Um das vielleicht nochmal so kurz zu erklären.
Eine ganze Sache ist, man hat eine mathematische Funktion, da schiebt man seine Zahl, die man verschlüsseln möchte, rein, es kommt auf der anderen Seite eine andere Zahl raus, die man übertragen kann, die auch, wenn sie jemand mitliest, dem nicht sehr viel bringt, ohne die Information des Schlüssels, das kann die Gegenseite dann dazu verwenden, um mit derselben mathematischen Funktion eben wieder diese Klartextnachricht zu bekommen. Und das Schicke bei modernen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen oder generell ist, dass die Funktion an sich, also mit der diese Zahl bearbeitet wird, bekannt sein kann, aber das Geheime der Schlüsse ist. Das macht einen guten Crypto-Algorithmus aus.
Also um das nochmal zusammenzufassen, ist es so bei allen früheren Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die man so kennt, also irgendwie Buchstaben, die man durch andere Buchstaben setzen oder Papier um einen Stab wickeln, oder was es da auch immer gab, ist immer die Sache gewesen, dass man, wenn man einmal die Technologie rausgefunden hat, dass man dann jede verschlüsselte Nachricht, egal welche Art und Weise man sich dann nochmal besonders ausgedacht hatte, dass man die dann sozusagen entschlüsseln konnte. Und heute ist es so, selbst wenn das Verfahren bekannt ist, solange der Schlüssel nicht bekannt ist, also die spezielle Art und Weise, wie ich in diesem einen Fall verschlüsselt habe, kam ich an die Nachricht nicht ran.
Die verschlüsselte Nachricht erlaubt dir keinen Rückschluss auf den Schlüssel oder auf ihren Inhalt.
Genau.
Und deswegen kannst du das Verfahren ruhig, also du kannst ruhig wissen, nach welchem Verfahren Schlüssel und Inhalt verwurstet wurden.
Dadurch, dass das Verfahren bekannt ist, weiß man auch, unter welchen Annahmen das Verfahren funktioniert. Eins, das bei verschlüsselten E-Mails zum Beispiel verwendet wird, basiert darauf, dass man keine großen Zahlen faktorisieren kann. Also wenn ich irgendwie Zahl 6 habe, dann weiß ich, das ist 2 mal 3. Aber das Verfahren beruht eben darauf, dass man eine ganz große Zahl hat, die aus zwei multiplizierten Zahlen besteht. Und solange Computer das nicht leisten können, bei einer bestimmten Länge an Zahlen, ist das Verfahren sicher. Man kann also mathematisch gesehen eine Aussage machen, unter welchen Bedingungen ein bestimmtes Verschlüsselungsverfahren sicher ist, und sich danach richten, um zum Beispiel Schlüssellängen auszuwählen und so weiter.
Ich bin jetzt so ein bisschen raus, aber ich habe verstanden, solange der Computer zu schwach ist, um die Mathematik brutal auszurechnen, ist das Verschlüsselungsverfahren sicher.
Na, in dem Moment, wo du so ein Verfahren kennst und weißt, wie das Verfahren funktioniert, weißt du, unter welchen Bedingungen das funktioniert. Und bei dem RSA-Verfahren, von dem ich gerade sprach, ist es eben so, dass die Grundannahme ist, dass Computer große Zahlen nicht in ihre Bestandteile, in ihre Faktoren zerlegen können. Und solange das funktioniert, und es da keine Abkürzung für gibt, funktioniert das Verschlüsselungsverfahren.
Okay, und das sozusagen, die Zahlen müssen umso größer werden, je schneller und leistungsfähiger Computer werden.
Also stell dir zum Beispiel...
Es müssen große Ordnungen größer sein, um dem eben vorzubeugen, ja.
Stell dir zum Beispiel vor, ich sag dir, das Geheimnis, was ich jetzt hier, oder das Verschlüsselte, was ich transferiere, ist jetzt 36. Und du weißt, das ist das Produkt von zwei Zahlen. Und eine davon ist mein Geheimnis. Dann kannst du jetzt irgendwie anfangen zu raten, wie wir sagen, drei, zwölf oder so. Dann kommst du irgendwann an den Punkt, durch reines Raten, dann irgendwie auf mein Geheimnis zu kommen. Wenn die Zahl aber groß genug ist, gibt es zu viele Möglichkeiten von zu vielen Faktoren, die ich genommen haben könnte, um auf diese Zahl zu kommen.
Okay, also es ist annehmbar sicher, kann man sagen.
Vor allem haben da über die letzten 30, 40 Jahre schon die schlausten Köpfe drauf geguckt, dort ein Verschlüsselungsverfahren nach dem nächsten empfohlen, immer wieder versucht kaputt zu spielen. Und das ist bei denen so ein Sport, dass sie sich immer wieder was Neues ausdenken auf die Art und Weise, wie sie das letzte geknackt haben. Und knacken heißt einfach, dass man die Möglichkeit, den Schlüsselraum so weit einschränkt, dass der Schlüssel am Ende auch nicht so weit als eine ganz große Zahl ist, die man alle durchprobieren muss. Und die Idee dabei ist ja, dass wenn dein Schlüssel einfach so lang ist, eine Zahl, die mehrere tausend Stellen hat, dann kann so ein Computer, die zwar alle durchzählen, da sind die halt stupide genug, das zu tun, brauchen die aber einfach ewig für. Und ewig heißt so was wie ein paar Millionen Mal, so oft wie das Universum schon alt ist, in der Größenordnung.
Die Idee ist halt, dass man das Verfahren abkürzt. Also dass man den Algorithmus, der läuft in irgendeiner Form, abkürzen kann. Und deswegen zeichnet es ein gutes Verfahren aus, dass es öffentlich ist.
Damit zu sagen, dass möglichst viele Leute darin rumspielen können und versuchen kann. Okay, ich fand das jetzt alles andere als einfach und das war erst der Anfang. Aber ich glaube, es wurde nach dem Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr noch wieder ein bisschen einfacher. Bis gleich.
Die neuen Deutschpoeten.
Jetzt auch mit Matzen. Freitag, 6. September mit Philipp Poisell und einen Tag später mit Maxim, Lying, Bosse, Mega-Mega, Sportfreunde Stiller und jetzt auch mit Matzen.
Freitag, 6. und Samstag, 7. September im IFA-Sommergarten der Messe Berlin.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt.
Im Kombi-Ticket für beide Tage oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. Die neuen Deutschpoeten 2013, weil Sprache lebt.
Nachrichten mit Golo Schmid.
Auch nach der heutigen Sitzung des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums sieht die Opposition in der Ausspäraffäre weiter Aufklärungsbedarf. Nach der dreistündigen Sitzung sagte der Ausschussvorsitzende und SPD-Politiker Oppermann, es sei immer noch nicht klar, wann und was die Bundesregierung über die Überwachungsaktion des US-Geheimdienstes NSA gewusst habe. Kanzleramtschef Pofalla wies den Vorwurf zurück, deutsche Bürger seien umfangreich durch den amerikanischen Geheimdienst ausgespäht worden. Der Datenschutz in Deutschland sei eingehalten worden, sagte Pofalla. Laut Oppermann will das Gremium nun im August zu zwei weiteren Sitzungen zusammenkommen. Das schwere Zugunglück in Spanien ist offenbar durch eine überhöhte Geschwindigkeit des Zuges verursacht worden. Der Lokführer soll Medienberichten zufolge eingeräumt haben, dass er mit 190 kmh unterwegs war, als der Schnellzug in der Nähe von Santiago de Compostela entgleiste. Zulässig war dort nur Tempo 80. Nach Angaben der staatlichen Bahngesellschaft gab es an dem Zug auch kein technisches Problem. Mindestens 80 Menschen kamen bei dem Unfall ums Leben. Mindestens 180 wurden verletzt. Ministerpräsident Rajoy ordnete drei Trage Staatstrauer an. Lediglich in der Nähe von St.Jago de Compostela in Gleiste. Zulässig war dort nur Tempo 80. Nach Angaben der staatlichen Bahngesellschaft gab es an dem Zug auch kein technisches Problem. Mindestens 80 Menschen kamen bei dem Unfall ums Leben. Mindestens 180 wurden verletzt. Ein dreitägiger Streik der Schleusenwärter hat den Schiffsverkehr auf der Spree in Berlin weitgehend lahm geledigt. Lediglich Ausflugsdampfer können noch auf dem kurzen Flussabschnitt zwischen Mühlendamm-Schleuse in Berlin-Mitte und der Schleuse Charlottenburg pendeln. Die Berliner Reedereien befürchten Umsatzeinbußen von etwa 30.000 Euro pro Tag. Auch in Brandenburg ist der Schiffsverkehr erheblich beeinträchtigt. Im zweiten Halbfinalspiel der Frauen Fußball-EM steht zwischen Norwegen und Dänemark 1 zu 1 unentschieden. Der Sieger dieser Partie trifft am Sonntag im Finale auf Deutschland. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Müggelheim 19°C, Tempelhof 26°C, Rangsdorf und Grünow jeweils 22°C, Frankfurt-Oder und Brandenburg an der Havel jeweils 23°C. In der Nacht bleibt es meist trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 18 bis 14°C runter. Morgen ist es dann überwiegend trocken bei Höchstwerten von knapp über 30°C. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding, zwischen Kurfürstendamm und Dreieck-Funkturm ist nur eine Spur frei. Zurzeit staut es sich ab Dreieck-Schmagendorf. Außerdem sind die Einfahrt Halenseestraße und die Ausfahrt Messe-Damm bis Anfang August gesperrt. Außerdem gibt es noch eine Vollsperrung vom Dreieck-Schmagendorf bis Jakob-Kaiserplatz bzw. Hecker-Damm in Richtung Wedding. A115 AWUS Richtung Berlin, am Dreieck-Funkturm ist die Tangente in Richtung A100 bis 5 Uhr gesperrt. Zum Verkehr in Brandenburg, A10 südlicher Berliner Ring zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf. Blockiert ein kaputtes Auto die rechte Spur in Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz und A113 Zubringer Schönefeld zwischen Dreieck-Waltersdorf und Schönefelder Kreuz sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Straße.
Da, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Kostenlos jetzt in eurem Google Play und App Store.
Heute mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Und obwohl wir gerade Nachrichten gehört haben, dass der Herr Profaller gesagt hat, also es hätte ja gar keine massenhafte Überwachung stattgefunden, wollen wir uns trotzdem mal mit Verschüßungen beschäftigen, weil ich glaube, die Anwesen den Herren Erdgeist Nibbler und Linus Glauben das nicht so richtig.
Ich weiß nicht, der Herr Profaller ist ja auch als brutalstmöglicher Aufklärer. Nein, ich glaube, der heißt Profaller, oder?
Nee, Profaller.
Ich dachte, es ist ein Scherz.
So, wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde... Das war jetzt sehr meta alles, ne? Wollen wir erstmal zusammenfassen, dass wir in der ersten halben Stunde gesagt haben, wir wollen heute mal ganz einfach Verschüßungen erklären, um dann mit abstrakten Konzepten um uns zu werfen. Wir halten erstmal fest, Verschlüsselungssoftware, Verschlüsselungsmechanismen in der heutigen Zeit ist komplizierte Mathematik, die sicher ist, solange man dafür sorgt, dass der eigene Schlüssel, also das, was man verwert, man kann sich als so eine Art überlanges Passwort vorstellen, immer geheim bleibt. Aber die Mechanik generell ist erstmal unangreifbar. Das Angebot ist heute, wenn wir das erklären, dann könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Entweder wenn ihr eine bessere Erklärung habt, die noch verständlicher ist, oder wenn ihr was nicht verstanden habt und nochmal genau erklären wollt. So, und das muss ich mir euch gleich antun und euch auch. Thomas hat nämlich angerufen. Thomas ist 22, kommt aus Braunschweig. Hallo Thomas.
Na, abends.
Und er hat eine Frage zur D-E-Mail, wenn ich es richtig lese.
Genau.
Was hast du denn für eine Frage?
Es ist ja schon mal thematisiert worden hier, dass dieses D-E-Mail-Gesetz, habt ihr es genannt, dazu dient auch, dass man bestimmte Dienstlöse zu zwingen möchte, sie zu nutzen. Was hab ich denn als Bürger für recht, einmal zu sagen, dass er das nicht benutzen darf, beziehungsweise dass ich der Behörde sage, ich kommuniziere mit euch nur über eben Unterstützung.
Ganz einfach.
Das Problem ist sozusagen, die Frage, die du gerade stellst, ist eine verwaltungsjuristische Frage. Und wir würden uns heute lieber mit den technischen Hintergründen beschäftigen.
Ist auch schon eine wichtige Frage. Also kann ein Nesche nur wieder sagen, sich die E-Mail freiwillig einzutreten.
Thomas, hast du das Radio noch an? Das ist sehr seltsam. Na gut.
Also sich die E-Mail einzutreten, sich da irgendwie einen Account zu holen und über die E-Mail erreichbar zu sein, das ist eine verdammt schlechte Idee.
Aber eigentlich können wir da schon mal ganz praktisch drüber reden, warum die E-Mail eine schlechte Idee ist. Weil, wie haben wir eben in der Kryptographie gesagt, wir müssen irgendwie so einen Schlüssel auf beiden Seiten verteilen, damit jemand verschlüsseln und auf der anderen Seite entschlüsseln kann. Und das ist eins der großen Pferdehüse der Kryptographie, ist, wie man diesen Schlüssel da jetzt verteilt, wie man dafür sorgt, dass du wirklich den selben Schlüssel hast wie ich. Und bei der D-E-Mail ist es so, dass der Starter einfach entscheidet, dass man das nicht braucht.
Der macht einem das einfach so, da braucht man sich nicht um den Schlüssel kümmern, sondern der Anbieter verschlüsselt für einen selber.
Damit hast aber das Problem, dass du keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bei D-E-Mail hast, weil du zur D-E-Mail hin verschlüsselst, die entschlüsselst wieder und verschlüsseln dann neu für den Empfänger. Somit ist die gesamte Vertraulichkeit der Nachricht einfach nur gegeben auf dem Weg bis zu demjenigen, der es entschlüsselt. Und auf der anderen Seite wird das wieder neu verschlüsselt. Deswegen ist genau D-E-Mail die falsche Richtung, die wir nicht propagieren wollen, weil wir Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung...
Also der Punkt ist...
die Vertritte der Nachricht...
Der Punkt bei D-E-Mail ist, dass sie Verschlüsselungen machen, wo sie unsinnig ist. Ich kann viel verschlüsseln, aber das Entscheidende ist, zwischen welchen beiden Instanzen ich verschlüssel. Und D-E-Mail verschlüsselt irgendwie 20 Mal zwischen 20 verschiedenen Punkten, während die Nachricht übertragen wird. Aber jeder einzelne Punkt kann die Nachricht wiederum mitlesen. Und dadurch wird es eigentlich auch wieder uninteressant, überhaupt diese Verschlüsselung einmal gemacht zu haben.
Also man könnte es auch so erklären, dass das, was euch der Chaos Computer Club hier vorstellen will, ist, die Nachricht wird beim Sender, also bei euch, verschlüsselt, dann beim Empfänger, also bei uns möglicherweise, entschlüsselt und nicht zwischendurch. Und D-E-Mail macht genau das. Zwischendurch wird die Nachricht entschlüsselt. Und zwar zufälligerweise an genau der Stelle, wo sie auch diese ganzen Überwachungs-Dachen abgreifen.
Das ist kein Zufall übrigens.
Ach es ist kein Zufall, nein. Doch. Also naja, also. Aber Thomas?
Das ist ungefähr so, als würde die Post, wenn man einen Brief in den Briefkasten wirft, kommt der Postbote, der den Briefkasten leert, guckt sich den Brief an, macht den erstmal auftütet, den in einen neuen Brief ein und reicht ihn weiter. Dann wird er beim Verteidiger nochmal aufgemacht, würde reingeguckt, ja, ist auch nur ein Brief, wieder zugemacht und weitergeschickt und ja.
Aber der Brief war ja die ganze Zeit im Umschlag.
Immer in irgendeinem Umschlag.
Genau, so Thomas hat das deine Frage beantwortet.
Genau, dann wollte ich noch fragen, dass bei Microsoft im Outlook ja dieser Vector drin ist. Erwähnt ihr das noch oder ist das heute an mich gedacht? Mit der Vector vor der Verschüttlung im Microsoft Outlook.
Kommen wir glaube ich am Ende nochmal zu.
Okay, dann danke ich.
Alles klar Thomas, vielen Dank. So, nicht auflegen, bevor wir auflegen. Das ist unhöflich und klingt im Radio doof.
Don't hang up on me, I hang up on you.
Psst, Ruhe jetzt. 40 Minuten in der Sendung. Ich würde jetzt gerne da anfangen, wo wir anfangen wollten. Ist das okay für euch? Dann mach mal.
Worum geht es in dieser Sendung eigentlich?
Es geht darum, dass ich zu meinen Eltern gehe und die gucken mich mit so großen Elternaugen an, wie sie das immer machen und fragen mich, Junge, du machst doch was mit Computern. Und wir haben gehört, die überwachen jetzt alles, was können wir denn da tun?
Also, eins der Dinge, die man tun kann, ist...
Ha, ich weiß es, ruft Vater. Das hat doch der Herr Friedrich gesagt. Ich installiere mir einen Virenscanner.
Und der kann dann die E-Mails verschlüsseln.
Ja, wie jetzt?
Okay, wahrscheinlich würde das Installieren des Virenscanners dazu führen, dass man dann auch öfter wieder vorbei muss, weil der Computer so langsam ist. Und Junge, mach doch meinen Computer wieder schnell. Ich glaube, das Virenscanner, da muss man auch mal eine eigene Chaosradio-Sendung dazu machen. Ziemlich viel Snake Oil dabei ist die...
Jetzt musst du den Begriff erklären.
Snake Oil ist so Schlangenöl. Das kommt aus den 1880er-Jahren im Wilden Westen, wo so ein Verkäufer auf einem Pferdewagen durch die Städte gereist ist und den Leuten gegen alle möglichen Krankheiten und wenig Haare und Impotenz ein Schlangenöl verkauft hat. Das Wort ist Quack-Cyber? Das heißt, dass viel von der heute im Umlauf befindlichen Anti-Viren-Software Quack-Cyber-Kram ist.
Aber zum Beispiel bei Windows gibt es die Möglichkeit, von Microsoft selber Dinge runterzuladen, was das mit übernimmt, so Basisfunktionalität. Sagt ihr jetzt wirklich, gar keinen Viren-Scanner installieren?
Man kann dieses Basisfunktionalitäts-Dings schon nehmen, aber man darf sich halt nicht damit belügen, dass das irgendwas hilft. Also am Ende des Tages ist das...
Es kostet dich viel Rechenzeit, es macht deinen Rechner total langsam und gibt am Ende einfach nur Geld in die Taschen von Firmen, die eigentlich, ja eigentlich sollte das Geld aus der Tasche von Microsoft kommen, die sollten dort einfach ihr Betriebssystem sicher machen und sie sollten dafür sorgen, dass du da keine Software auf deinem Rechner laufen hast, von der du das nicht möchtest. Aber ich glaube, das fühlt hier an der Stelle auch nicht so weit.
Okay, also über Wien-Scanner können wir mal reden, aber ich nehme dem so grob so, also wenn der Wien-Scanner gar keine Probleme macht, kann man ihn auch dalassen, aber auf jeden Fall höchstens einen. Und vielleicht auch nicht mal den. Gut.
Aber das Profalo, dass es auf den wird, hat überhaupt nichts mit Prism Tempora oder dem aktuellen Abhörskandal zu tun.
Darf ich sagen, das zeigt einfach, wie kompetent der Herr Profalo ist?
Die darfst du sagen. Gut, können sich alle ihr eigenes Bild.
Also wir in Scanlern sind erstmal raus. Was kann ich meinen Eltern aber Gutes tun?
Deinen Eltern Gutes tun? Es gibt Werkzeuge, die ziemlich unter dem Radar bleiben, aber schon mal grob helfen, beim Besuch von Webseiten, die verschlüsselte Version zu benutzen. Es gibt einen großen Index von Seiten, die sowohl in verschlüsselte als auch unverschlüsselte Versionen zu erreichen sind. Und man kann jetzt ein Plugin in einen Browser installieren, die dazu führen, dass wenn beide Versionen angeboten werden und beide Versionen auch identischen Content ausliefern, dass dann einfach die Variante in verschlüsselt mit dem sogenannten HTTPS, also Secure Protocol, über eine verschlüsselte Verbindung abgerufen werden. Dieses Projekt heißt HTTPS Everywhere und ist eine ziemlich niedrig hängender Frucht, um schon mal einen Großteil der Kommunikationen, die deine Eltern wahrscheinlich eh mit dem Internet stattfinden lassen, zu verschlüsseln.
Also das ist halt dann nur sicher, dass sozusagen die Informationen, die das Netz rauschen, sozusagen mit dem Betreiber der Seite und mir ausgetauscht werden und zwischendurch die Leute halt nichts sehen können.
Das ist grob die Idee. Und wenn du die Idee zu Ende denkst, findet ein Großteil der Kommunikationen des Computers mit dem Internet eh über dieses HTTP-Protokoll statt. Viele, viele Dienste sind sowieso im Browser, seien es irgendwelche komischen Webmailer, seien es Zeitungsangebote, sind es Google Docs. Und wenn du dann da immer auf die verschlüsselte Version geschubst wirst, dann kannst du im Ende gar nicht anders als zu verschlüsseln und hast damit einfach das Grundrauschen schon erhöht. Und natürlich ist ja die Kommunikation mit dem Diensteanbieter in dieser schönen Cloud, da gehen ja auch keine unwichtigen Daten drüber. Also auf der einen Seite hörst du das Rauschen, auf der anderen Seite schützt du dann auch wirklich die Inhalte, die da ausgetauscht werden.
Und das funktioniert aber tatsächlich auch so gut, weil manchmal, wenn man Zusatzplugins installiert, also ich kenne das zum Beispiel irgendwie, es gibt Dinge, die so Flash unterbinden und das funktioniert immer. Aber bei Eltern ist es dann komisch, wenn eine Webseite dann nicht mehr so funktioniert, weil irgendwie so ganz vergraben, irgendwie so ein Flash-Element drin ist, was eine wichtige Funktionalität der Seite, man sieht es aber dann nicht mehr. Ist dieses HTTPS Everywhere, es hört sich so an, wie das macht wirklich nur dann was, wenn es wirklich wirklich funktioniert. Also da kriege ich keinen Folgeanruf von meinen Eltern.
Das guckt halt, ob der Server, mit dem der Benutzer sprechen möchte, ob der auch verschlüsseln kann. Und wenn der auch verschlüsseln kann, dann macht er das.
So, dann surfen also meine Eltern in Zukunft verschlüsselt. Jetzt ist es ja aber so, wenn die mit mir reden wollen, dann tun die das ja meistens nicht über eine Weboberfläche, die man dann mit HTTPS verschlüsseln kann, sondern weil es so schön einfach ist, nehmen sie Skype. Jetzt hab ich gehört, Skype verschlüsselt ja.
Ist das also super? Na, Skype verschlüsselt auch, aber wie ich vorhin schon erwähnte, muss ja ein Schlüssel her, der auf beiden Seiten gleich ist. Also wenn du nur eine Seite hast, die verschlüsselt, und die andere Seite hat den Schlüssel nicht, dann ist es essig, weil die andere Seite kannst du einfach stumpflich entschlüsseln. Oder wenn sich jeder seinen eigenen Schlüssel ausdenkt, dann hast du dann am Ende auch nichts von. Was Skype an der Stelle tut, ist in einer zentralen Instanz für dich Schlüssel auswürfeln und an beide Seiten denselben Schlüssel verteilen, sodass am Ende Skype den Daumen drauf hat. Es findet zwar eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung statt, aber der Schlüssel, den weiß Skype auch. Und wie auch bekannt geworden ist im Zuge der Prisenenthüllung, kann der US-amerikanische Geheimdienst auch in Konversationen von Skype mit rein lauschen. Auf der anderen Seite ist Skype schon mal mehr Crypto als nicht. Also du hast da schon mal, wenn du Skype benutzt, ist schon mal Kryptographie an. Das hilft schon mal gegen den Nachbarn. Der kann dir da nicht in deine Kommunikation reingucken, aber die Informationen fallen an zentraler Stelle an und werden auch nicht wirklich Ende-zu-Ende verschlüsselt, ohne Option, dass jemand außer dir und deinem Gegenüber reingucken kann.
Also das heißt, es hilft sozusagen, sich vorzustellen, im Prinzip ist Skype wie das Webbrowsing-Ding mit dem HTTPS Everywhere. Ich verschlüsselte zwar, aber der Anbieter selber weiß natürlich noch, was ich da treibe. Und auch alle Anbieter, also alle Dienste, mit denen der Anbieter zusammenarbeitet, weiß das auch. Also im Prinzip ist ein Gespräch über Skype sowas wie ein Gespräch über Twitter, was über HTTPS läuft, weil der Twitter weiß natürlich, was ich da schreibe. Okay, so jetzt habt ihr in die Liste auch etwas aufgeschrieben, was jetzt also auf den ersten Blick gar nicht zusammenpasst mit, wir kommunizieren über das Internet, nämlich Festplattenverschlüsselung. Warum gehört das damit rein und was machen meine Eltern damit?
Na du hebst deinen Schlüssel ja auch irgendwo auf. Das machst du auf deiner Festplatte. Und das wäre ja blöd, wenn der da nicht, also wenn da so der Schlüssel rumliegt, dann sollte der auch sicher liegen.
Stell dir vor, du wirst am Flughafen gebeten, mal kurz zu einer Sprengstoffkontrolle deinen Rechner abzugeben. Und dann nehmen die halt mal eine Kopie von dem, was sie da drauf finden und nehmen dann schon mal vorausschauend die Schlüssel, die sie da finden, nehmen sie mit. So der Bundestrojaner wurde ja auf diese Art und Weise auf dem Rechner von Verdächtigen vom Zeug Kriminalat installiert. Das heißt, dass es gang und gäbe ist, einfach wenn du dein Notebook aus der Hand gibst, dass da schon mal auch Dinge mit passieren. Und so Festplattenverschlüsselung sorgt dafür. Natürlich musst du dein Betriebssystem nicht verschlüsseln, weil das ist eigentlich bekannt, was du mit dem Betriebssystem drauf hast. Aber auf der Festplatte befinden sich viele spannende Dinge, die einfach nicht in fremde Hände gehören. Und da es inzwischen einfach so einfach ist und da auch Kryptographie von Computern heutzutage fast ohne Zeitaufwand erledigt werden kann, ist es eigentlich ein No-Go, ein No-Brain, einfach Kryptographie auch für die Festplattenverschlüsselung anzubauen.
Also, ich will jetzt nicht, halt!
Leute, Leute, Leute, ihr vergesst, dass ich hier die Regeln in der Hand habe. Was ich sagen wollte ist, also es hört sich für mich zu sein, es geht hier an dieser Stelle nicht um die konkrete Kryptographierung, Verschlüsselung von Kommunikation über das Internet, aber es geht auch hier darum, so ein Standard von Kryptohygiene, nenne ich es mal, zu etablieren, das man halt sozusagen seine persönlichen Daten einfach so gut schützt, wie es geht. Damit sie halt im Teufel nicht wegkommen. Aber Linus, du wolltest jetzt sowas sagen.
Ja, ich kann dir jetzt gerade ganz kurz erklären, wieso Festplattenverschlüsselung so sinnvoll ist, weil mir vor einiger Zeit ein Computer geklaut wurde. Und wer diese Situation schon einmal hatte, weiß, dass das eine sehr schlechte Situation ist, weil man sich natürlich dann sehr viele Gedanken darüber macht, welche Daten, Dateien da jetzt alles drauf sind. Und auch Mama und Papa haben ja so eine Kamera mit, der sie manchmal Fotos machen. Und das könnte ja alles auf so einem Computer sein, der verloren geht. Und selbst wenn Mama und Papa noch so eine stationäre Dampfmaschine da stehen haben, kann die ja auch bei einem Einbruch gestohlen werden. Und da werden ja Steuererklärungen drauf gemacht auf solchen Computern. Da werden sehr viele persönliche private...
Nacktfotos von Freunden oder Freundinnen?
Kann man auch auf Computern speichern, habe ich gehört.
Deine Passwörter für die Webservices, über die du kommunizierst.
Und das war zum Beispiel dann bei meinem Computer der Fall. Da waren dann halt so um die 500 Zugangspasswörter irgendwie... Zu drauf. Und ich war dann in der glücklichen Position, dass dieser Computer einerseits die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt hatte, sowie meine persönlichen Daten dann innerhalb dessen noch einmal verschlüsselt hatte, sodass ich sehr beruhigt davon ausgehen konnte, dass wenn jetzt der Dieb meines Rechners nicht ein Geheimdienst ist, der über Fähigkeiten verfügt, von denen ich nicht ausgehe, dass er sie hat, meinen Computer da jetzt einen angenehmen praktischen Türkeil für diese Personen bietet.
Naja, er könnte den schon noch platt machen und neu aufsetzen.
Nee, auch das nicht, weil ich meinen Computer so eingerichtet habe, dass er nur von dieser einen Festplatte oder dieser einen SSD bootet und die ist in den Computer reingelötet, weil ich einen Apple habe. Der Computer war dann wirklich jetzt, hoffentlich lehne ich mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster, aber der war ein, der sollte dann für den durchschnittlich oder auch überdurchschnittlich begabten Dieb eine Herausforderung darstellen, die nur mit sehr, sehr viel Geld zu meistern ist und hoffentlich übersteigt dieser Geldbetrag den Wert, den diese Daten für meinen Computer Dieb hatten.
Also sagen, es wäre für ihn billiger, sich einfach ein neues Gerät zu kaufen, statt da hin zu entschlüsseln.
Man hat dann den Vorteil, mein Computer zeigt dann im Falle des verschlossen Seins dem Nutzer direkt meine Telefonnummer an und stellt eine Belohnung in Aussicht für den ehrlichen Finder.
Hat aber keiner angerufen.
Nee, es war ja ein unehrlicher Finder.
Er hätte scheinehrlich sein können.
Aber man hätte also, ich sehe das so einmal im Jahr, wenn ich an einer S-Bahn-Haltestelle diese Dinge hilfe, mein Computer wurde geklaut, da sind zwei Jahre Doktorarbeit drauf. Das ist jetzt die Backup-Problematik.
Das ist aber eine wichtige Problematik, die da plötzlich auftaucht. Wenn du nämlich anfängst, mathematisch sicher deine Daten auf deiner Festplatte so zu verschlüsseln, dass da niemand mehr rankommt, der das Passwort nicht hat, dann vergiss besser das Passwort nicht oder habe noch irgendwo ein Backup. Weil sonst kommt der Folgeanruf von den Eltern, den man ja vermeiden wollte. Junge, ich komm da gerade meine Daten nicht rein. Und das ist natürlich dann auch unangenehm.
Wir haben den gelben Zettel am Bildschirm, wo dieses Passwort drauf stand, verloren.
Das ist übrigens auch noch eine Elternfrage, die müssen wir auch noch beantworten. Aber jetzt, bevor das überhaupt passieren kann, also dass die Eltern das nicht gebacked haben, wie ist denn dann die Verschlüsselung überhaupt eingerichtet? Auf ihren Systemen. Ihr redet die ganze Zeit von Festplattenverschlüsselung. Wie macht man es denn jetzt?
Da kommt ja immer drauf an, welchen Computer du hast. Okay, da gibt es... Ja, das würden wir empfehlen, aber es gibt ja inzwischen schon von Microsoft selber mit ausgeliefert. Ab nach bestimmten Tiefen deiner Tasche, wo du bereit bist, Geld auszugeben, ist da BitLocker mit installiert. Und BitLocker ist einfach ins Betriebssystem integrierte Festplatten-Vollverschlüsselung. Setzt mal ein Häkchen, fängt im Hintergrund an zu verschlüsseln. Alles knorke. Blöderweise musst du dafür mindestens die, ich will jetzt nicht lügen, Windows 7 Ultima, düschen. Ist ja sehr verwirrend. Aber wenn du da BitLocker dabei hast, dann ist das einfach so in diesen Systemsteuerungs-Sicherheits-Dingsbumms. Klickst du da einfach Festplatten-Krypto an und dann fängt er an loszurattern. Und da gibt es dann eigentlich wenig Ausreden, warum man das nicht tun sollte.
Das ist auf jeden Fall hinterher sicherer als vorher. Ob das jetzt wirklich hundertprozentig ist, ist halt das Problem bei einem Software, in dem man nicht reinschauen kann. Aber es ist schon mal besser als unverschlüsselt.
Also gibt es Untersuchungen über Bitlocker, wie sicher das dann macht? Also ich weiß nicht genau, was du mit deinem Computer angestellt hast, aber ist das auch so was, wenn man so eine Bitlocker Festplatte hat und man wirft den Computer weg, oder er wird geklaut, ist das dann auch sicher? Oder ist das eher so ein...
Ich habe ein Mac, ich habe die normale Mac Full Disk Encryption genutzt.
Dazu kommen wir gleich.
Es gab da mal eine Analyse, die dieses Verfahren sich angeschaut hat, wo dann geprüft wurde, was machen die da und so, wie erstellen die die Keys für diese Vollverschlüsselung. Und das kam erst mal so zu dem Ergebnis, dass das einen ganz soliden Eindruck macht, was sie machen, aber was als Achillesferse gesehen wurde, war, wie dieses Betriebssystem sich quasi den langen, geheimen Krypto-Schlüssel errechnet. Und dafür brauch ich ja möglichst viel Zufall, damit der Angreifer nicht erraten kann, welchen Schlüssel dieses Betriebssystem eventuell gebaut hat. Und wir reden da wie gesagt immer so von Potenzen, wenn ich da den lösen soll. Und ich vertraue der Mac-Verschlüsselung so nicht 100%, deswegen habe ich ja die privaten Dateien dann darin noch einmal mit einem eigenen Verfahren nochmal verschlüsselt.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich erst mal BitLocker wissen. Das fragte ich doch.
Ja, aber dann warum fragst du mich denn?
Das Problem ist, dass uns bei BitLocker tatsächlich nicht sagen kann, weil Microsoft da nicht mit dem Quellcode rausrückt. Wenn man da sicherer gehen möchte, kann man TrueCrypt nehmen. Ich habe gerade gelesen, das kann das tatsächlich auch. Also ein bestehendes System, Verschlüsseln, ohne dass man alles neu installieren muss.
Aber ist das auch etwas, was man seinen Eltern antun will? Also funktioniert das dann nachproblemlos?
Ja, wenn sie vorher kein Passwort eingegeben haben, um sich in ihren Rechner einzuloggen, dann muss man ihnen erzählen, dass sie jetzt ein Passwort brauchen, um sich in ihren Computer einzuloggen. Das ist natürlich der Ärger oder das Sicherheitsfeature. Man kann natürlich auch, wenn man da hingeht und TrueCrypt anmacht oder irgendeine Festplattenvollverschlüsselung, kann man natürlich noch gleichzeitig den Rechner schneller machen, indem man z.B. eines der unnötigen Antivirenprogramme deinstalliert. Und dann sagt so, Mutti, ich hab dir mal Crypto angemacht, das ist dein Rechner schneller. Und da wird gleich eine positive...
Können wir das auf dem Fernseher und der Spülmaschine vielleicht auch anmachen, dieses Crypto?
Dieses TrueCrypt, das ist dann jetzt Open Source und deswegen vertrauenswürdiger?
Das ist Open Source und frei und hat irgendwie noch lauter andere nifty Features, die man dann... Da kommen wir später dazu, sowas wie Hidden Volumes und...
Also TrueCrypt mag zwar funktionieren, wenn man es seinen Eltern installiert, das ist aber was, da muss man sich selber erstmal ordentlicher mit beschäftigen.
TrueCrypt muss man sich nicht nüden, das zeige ich auch click and go.
Aber es ist einmal zusätzlich, also man nicht nur Betriebssystem installieren, sondern noch eine Zusatzsoftware.
Das ist nochmal eine Software installieren.
Das ist nicht nur Häckchen dran machen, sondern Software installieren, Häckchen dran machen. Also kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, wie viel mehr Aufwand das wirklich ist?
Ja, wir sind ja noch bei der einfachen Schwierigkeitsschuhe, finde ich. Deswegen schieben wir das mal in die nächste. Und es gibt dann noch die beiden anderen großen Betriebssysteme. Was ist denn bei OS X? Apple? Du hast ja jetzt so was. Was kann das? Wie macht das?
Bei OS X ist es auch eingebaut. Man kann das in den Systemeinstellungen, ich glaube ab Lion oder so war es dann dabei, wirklich in Häkchen setzen. Das läuft nahtlos. Man muss nur aufpassen. Apple ist so... Wir haben ja schon das Problem angesprochen. Wenn man dann diesen Schlüssel wirklich mal vergessen sollte, dann kommt man wirklich nicht mehr an die Daten ran. Und da Apple dieses Problem mit seinen Nutzern nicht haben möchte, bietet Apple an, hey, wir haben gerade so jetzt deine Festplatte verschlüsselt und wenn du jetzt dieses Passwort vergisst oder den Schlüssel, dann kannst du den nicht mehr entschlüsseln. Deswegen bieten wir dir an, schick uns doch diesen Schlüssel.
Nein, den Masterkey, aber ja...
Wir geben den für dich auf.
Wir heben den für dich sicher auf und dann kannst du, wenn du drei persönliche Fragen beantwortest oder so...
Oder nicht, wenn du drei persönliche Fragen beantwortest, wenn jemand drei persönliche Fragen beantworten kann.
Bekommt er den? Und wenn die NSA uns eine persönliche Frage stellt, bekommen sie die wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich finde das nur konsequent, weil wenn du eh deine Daten auf deinem Mac alle in deine iCloud hochlädst, dann sind die Daten ja eh schon mal redundant vorgehalten. Dann kann man Apple auch noch den Schlüssel für seine Festplatte hochschicken.
Womit wir eben...
Aber eigentlich wollten wir ja hier gar nicht... Wir wollten einfach nur mal sagen, wo ist das Häkchen, wo kann man schon mal mehr Sicherheit machen als vorher. Und das Häkchen ist da einfach auch eine Systemsteuerung, die heißt da irgendwie anders.
System Preference.
Ich weiß ja nämlich, wie sie auf Deutsch heißt.
Ich frag mich bei der ganzen Problematik, wie viele Leute inzwischen bei der NSA angerufen haben, weil sie ihr Passwort für irgendwas vergessen haben.
Also BitLocker kann man anmachen, man kann FileVault heißt das da anmachen und dann sollte man nur darauf achten, dass das Passwort nicht in Apple geschrieben wird, aber dass man sich trotzdem irgendwo aufschreibt. Dann gibt es das dritte System und tatsächlich, das wurde im Chat zur Sendung auch gerade gefragt, manche Eltern haben ja Ubuntu. Wie ist das denn überhaupt bei Linux? Gibt es da sowas auch?
Muss man sich vorher ausdenken. Aber inzwischen sind alle Installer, soweit ich das gehört habe, sind alle Installer gleich mit einem. Möchtest du das nicht?
Bei Linux alle ist glaube ich immer so ein bisschen eine Sache.
Also bei den großen Kinder Linuxen, Ubuntu und wie heißt auch das alle? Debian ist ja nicht gerade für die Eltern. Genau. Da gibt es einfach so Häkchen. Möchtest du verschlüsseln, dann wirst du da auch nicht weiter mit den Details belästigt, sondern kannst einfach Passwort eingeben und dann ist gut.
Aber, jetzt habe ich ja gerade erst die Sendung gehört. Und dann sagen die Eltern, ja hier Festplattenverschlüsselung, wir haben das im Radio gehört. Diese sympathischen jungen Männern haben gesagt, das geht, mach das bitte. So, dann ist das Linux aber schon installiert. Und dann muss ich also das System nur aufsetzen. Und da gibt es dann auch so vielleicht eine Zwischenlösung.
Also ich persönlich benutze FreeBSD. Da geht das nicht so einfach. Linux müsste wahrscheinlich mal jemand, der mit Linux regelmäßig spielt, was dazu sagen.
Ich kann wenig dazu sagen, weil ich seitdem das geht, dass man seine komplette Festplatte verschlüsselt, dass man das dann auch macht.
Also bei der Installation. Herr Neumann, Sie sehen vielleicht noch einen Vorschlag?
Na, also vielleicht kann man ja doch durchaus darauf hinweisen, dass Full-Disk-Encryption natürlich schon der sinnvolle Weg ist.
Also hat den Vorteil, dass man dann den Computer auch mal hibernähten, also einschlafen lassen kann und den kompletten Arbeitsspeicherinhalt in diese verschlüsselte Partition reindumpft. Das heißt, der Schlüssel, der normalerweise im Arbeitsspeicher steht, wird dann da in den verschlüsselten Teil geschrieben. Und wenn ich das nächste Mal meinen Computer wieder aufmache und da wieder darauf zugreifen möchte, dann steht der Schlüssel nicht im Arbeitsspeicher, sondern wird da wieder von der verschlüsselten Platte gelesen. Das heißt, ich muss ihn eingeben.
Okay, also das wäre cool. Aber wie gesagt, wir sind ja gerade an einem Punkt, wo es möglicherweise nicht geht.
Dann würde ich also eine normale verschlüsseltes Verzeichnislösung empfehlen. EnkFS oder E-CryptFS ist glaube ich auch dann bei jedem Ubuntu clickable.
Was heißt das jetzt sagen, da werden die Dateien nochmal extra verschlüsselt?
Da wird einfach statt der kompletten Festplatte nur ein Ordner verschlüsselt.
Hat natürlich den Nachteil, dass es unsicherer ist, weil der Schlüssel im Arbeitsspeicher steht.
Aber besser als nichts.
Könnte es aber natürlich dem Ding trotzdem beibringen, dass bevor es schlafen geht, es diesen Schlüssel wieder vergisst.
Das ist sozusagen die Zwischenlösung und das nächste Mal, wenn wir das Thema neu aufsetzen, machen wir den Haken gleich am Anfang. Gut, wir geben uns also auch heute zufrieden mit besser als nichts hier. Nein, das wollte ich jetzt nicht machen. Das wollte ich eigentlich schon lange wieder rausgenommen haben.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Morgen bring ich sie um. Morgen bring ich sie um. Wenn ihr euch fragt, wovon ich rede, ich rede von Leuten, die hier vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio zu Gast sind. Auf den Namen Erdgeist, Nibbler und Linus hören. Hallo Gunther nochmal. Und die heute mal erklären wollen Ansätze. Also wir machen heute hier Cryptoparty. Entsprechend geht es hier auch zu. Aber es gibt auch etwas Sinnvolles dabei zu lernen, nämlich die Anfänge von Verschlüsselung. Wir haben schon grob erklärt, wie Verschlüsselung überhaupt funktioniert. Und haben jetzt so die Verschlüsselung, die man seinen Eltern mal installieren kann. Also Dinge, die das Computerleben sicherer machen, aber die trotzdem, wenn sie erst mal da sind, so einfach zu benutzen sind, dass sie niemanden mehr verwirren. Und jetzt hatte gerade noch jemand angerufen, der eine Frage zur Festplattenverschlüsselung hatte und der jetzt in dem Moment, wo ich ihn drannehmen wollte, aufgelegt hat.
So macht das natürlich keinen Sinn.
Ihr könnt immer sozusagen, das ist nämlich das Angebot in der Sendung, auch anrufen, wenn ihr eine Verständnisfrage habt oder etwas noch besser erklären könnt als die drei Gäste, die hier in der Sendung sitzen und das erklären wollen. Ich glaube, wir kriegen den Carlo, der da angerufen hatte, gleich nochmal rein. Und genau da ist er. Hallo Carlo.
Ja, hallo.
Du hattest noch eine Frage zur Festplattenverschlüsselung, die wir ja gerade erklärt haben.
Genau, aber im Webstream wurden schon einige Sachen beantwortet. Ja, aber da war jetzt so die Frage Bitlocker oder TrueCrypt oder verschlüssel ich jetzt meinen USB-Stick, den ich verlieren kann, mit TrueCrypt oder ist das jetzt, sag ich mal, für Freunde, Familie zu kompliziert oder wie bringt man denen das vernünftig bei?
Ausprobieren.
Also du hörst dich schlau genug an, als ob du das einfach mal installieren kannst. Und wenn es dir zu schwer fällt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich für deine Eltern auch nichts. Aber du konntest ja schon so grob das Gefühl dafür entwickeln, wo die Fallstricke sind, die du selber beim Installieren hast und danach kannst du empfehlen. Also ich hab da sehr gute Erfahrungen mitgemacht und es ist inzwischen einfach klicken und vergessen. Geht einfach.
Okay, gut. Und wie kann man den Leuten das mal beibringen, wenn die jetzt ihren neuen USB-Stick kaufen, dass sie den dann auch wirklich verschlüsseln? Also da ist ja auch immer viel V-Herrheit dabei, ja?
Puh, man muss doch halt USB-Sticks kaufen, die gleich Verschlüsselung mit eingebaut haben. Da gibt's ja welche, wo du den Fingerabdruck drüberfahren musst.
Also was da Carlo vielleicht nicht weiß, ist, dass der Chaos Computer Club auch der Club ist, der mal Fingerabdrücke zum Nachbau eine Anleitung dafür gestellt hat. Also die Frage nochmal, die Hände verblüht ist...
Ich hab diese Sendung über Fingerabdrücke gehört, ja.
Nicht mal die Hörer lassen mich hier noch reden. Also die Frage, die sich dahinter versteckt, ist ja sozusagen, dieses TrueCrypt ist auch anwendbar auf USB-Sticks? Kann man die dann auch an Rechnern betreiben, auf denen kein TrueCrypt installiert ist?
Du meinst, man kann sie auf Rechnern betreiben, wo noch kein TrueCrypt installiert ist?
Kann man die auf Rechnern betreiben?
Ja, wenn da mehrere Partitionen drauf sind, dann kann man auch diese USB-Sticks auf... Na, Partitionen ist ja die Art und Weise, wie man Festplatten in mehrere kleine virtuelle Festplatten unterteilt. Und man muss nicht alle Partitionen auf seinem USB-Stick, wenn man da mehrere Partitionen eingerichtet hat, kann man eine verschlüsseln.
Das heißt, man kann den USB-Stick aufteilen, dass man einen verschlüsselten Teil hat und einen unverschlüsselten Teil...
Okay, aber den unverschlüsselten Teil kommt man nicht ran, wenn der Rechner noch keinen TrueCrypt installiert hat.
Doch, an den unverschlüsselten Teil kommt man ran.
Man macht es sich doch noch einfacher. Man legt einfach auf den unverschlüsselten Teil dieses USB-Sticks...
TrueCrypt.
TrueCrypt. Und da liegt einfach die Binary drauf, die ich brauche, um das wieder zu entschlüsseln. Preferabel direkt für die gängigen Betriebssysteme kompiliert und alles ist gut. Oder der Installer, damit man halt auch mal auf seinem Weg über die anderen Computer auch Spuren hinterlässt und den Menschen Gutes tut. Also eine Art Verschlüsselungsleiter.
Also pack ich...
Darf ich nochmal? Also nehme ich meinen USB-Stick, pack da einen TrueCrypt-Container drauf und tu da einen Mac-Installer drauf und einen Windows-Installer und dann kommt man damit gut zurecht.
Genau, dann tust du da in den verschlüsselten Teil was rein, was deine Eltern unbedingt wollen und sagst dann klar, ihr müsst euch nur diese Entschlüsselungssoftware installieren.
So und ich hab die Sendung nicht von ganz Anfang gehört. Ihr habt ein bisschen so über E-Mail-Verschlüsselgeräte. Habt ihr schon über Pretty Good Privacy-Geräte?
So ein bisschen, aber es kommt eigentlich noch. Ja, es kommt noch. So Theorie dahinter so ein bisschen, aber so richtig, kommen wir noch.
Ja, okay, weil das hab ich auch nie geschafft, bei irgendwelchen Leuten zu etablieren.
Möglicherweise scheitern auch wir heute dran, aber wir werden noch mal einen Versuch starten. Carlo, vielen Dank erst mal. Und viel Spaß noch. Und dann haben wir noch den Mo. Hallo Mo.
Grüße.
Auch noch eine Frage zur Verschlüsselung.
Na ja, eine Frage und eine Anmerkung. Und zwar habt ihr meiner Meinung nach bis jetzt diesen ganzen Hardware-Spaß vergessen. Und zwar gibt es da von SSDs den schönen Cent-Force-Controller. Der hat einfach AES eingebaut. Und Hitachi nennt seinen ganzen Spaß BTE Bulk Disk Encryption. Und bei Western Digital Platten nennt die das Full-Disk Encryption. Die sind angeblich auch im Militär von der USA zugelassen. Mit einer FIPS-140-Tätigierung.
Du redest gerade über Sachen, die niemand mehr versteht. Die niemand mehr versteht, außer die Leute, die im Studio sitzen, die eh schon wissen, wovon du redest.
Aber bei denen hat er auch angerufen.
Leute, der Punkt ist, es gibt also Festplatten, die Hardware-Verschlüsselung.
Also das ist sozusagen eine Verschlüsselungsfunktion in der Festplatte eingebaut. Das ist dann nicht eine Software, die auf deinem Computer läuft, sondern die Festplatte verschlüsselt selbst.
Und wann fragt die mich nach dem Passwort?
Irgendwie muss der Schlüssel da auch noch mal wieder hin.
Na ja, der Schlüssel von den Kisten ist in den ersten, ich sag mal jetzt, Segmenten oder ersten Clustern der Festplatte mit drinne, der wiederum verschlüsselt ist und dann über dieses IDA Security abgefragt wird.
Das heißt, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr. Beim Einschalten will der Computer von dir ein Passwort haben. Und mit wem wird der Schlüssel entschlüsselt, mit dem dann die Festplatte verschlüsselt ist, kann man nutzen. Aber das Problem ist, du kannst es halt nicht überprüfen. Also das kann für zertifiziert und alles Mögliche sein, aber du weißt halt nicht, ob dein Schlüssel, den du da eingibst, also dein Passwort das einzige Passwort ist, dass du den Schlüssel verschlüsselt. Das hat man beispielsweise bei Netzwerkfestplatten schon das öfteren gesehen. Da ist die zwar total coole funktionierende Krypto machen, aber wenn man dann reinguckt, dann sieht man, da gibt es fünf Speicherplätze für Passworter. Und standardmäßig, wenn das Gerät kommt, ist schon einer belegt. Wenn man dann einen hinzufügt, dann sind da noch drei frei. Das heißt, es ist ein Passwort schon vergeben, was wohl in der Fabrik da reingewandert ist.
Falls du deins vergisst, muss natürlich auch jemand... Das finde ich schon sehr vorausschauend von der Firma.
Also grundsätzlich kann man sowas gerne verwenden, aber man sollte sich nicht drauf verlassen. Im Zweifel einfach noch mal...
Aber wie sieht das aus, weil kryptomäßig krieg ich das doch gar nicht hin, das mit fünf Passworten zuverschlüsseln.
Na doch, der Trick ist der, dass du da so einen Schlüssel hast. Und...
Du legst nebeneinander einfach fünf verschiedene Versionen, die du jeweils mit einem anderen Schlüssel verschlüsselst. Und wenn es entschlüsselt, kommt dann der wirkliche Schlüssel raus. Das ist üblicherweise die Idee. Aber wir sind gerade dabei, irgendwie eher die niedrig hängenden Früchte zu besprechen und neue Festplatten für die Eltern zu kaufen. Ist halt für die meisten Leute da irgendwie grad nicht drin. Die wollen einfach hin und mal schnell ein wenig was installieren, ein bisschen was klicken. Und die könnten dann später noch mal darauf zurückkommen, wenn wir dann in den Aluhutbereich kommen. Da können wir uns dann die Festplatten, die irgendwie ihre Krypto schon mitbringen, dann noch mal näher angucken.
Ja, also es geht heute vor allem darum, dass man die einfachen Sachen erklärt. Du hattest noch eine Frage?
Na ja, meine Frage war eigentlich schon beantwortet. Es ging ja eigentlich um die, wie ihr die Sicherheit von dem Zeug einschätzt. Weil, wie gesagt, ich hab dann eine schöne Lösung für meinen Fatih umgesetzt, ohne dass der den Schlüssel eingeben muss. Der wird einfach über Linux sozusagen, jedes Mal, wenn er hochfährt, über die Enid RD aus dem Internet geladen, aus zwei verschiedenen Stellen, was wiederum mit PGP verschlüsselt ist und dann dort lokal anschlüsselt wird. Und damit kann ich ja den Schlüssel sozusagen auf die Festplatte legen.
Das zählt definitiv nicht zu den einfachen Lösungen, die wir heute den Leuten erklären können. Aber es ist ein interessanter Ansatz.
Klingt auch so, als wäre das nicht so hundertprozentig.
Vielleicht könntet ihr die Diskussion aufwärmen.
Kommt noch mal in den IRC. Free Note, Routel, Chaos Radio. Können wir uns noch mal kurz drunterhalten? Das würde mich interessieren. Kann man gerne machen.
Wir haben noch einen, den Max aus Baden-Württemberg. Hallo Max.
Hallo, ich hab das mal ausprobiert mit einer Festverschlüsselung. Ich hatte das Problem, dass mein System danach so langsam war, dass ich nichts mehr benutzen konnte. Da wollte ich wissen, wie kann man das machen.
Was hast du da benutzt?
Fedora, da gab es irgendwo so einen Haken, wo Verschlüsselung gesagt wurde. Toll, nehme ich Verschlüsselung. Hab es genommen und dann habe ich festgestellt, es dauert so lange. Ich konnte dem einen Kaffee trinken gehen, bis das System irgendwas gemacht hat, bis es meinen Aufblick ausgeführt hat.
Das ist ja keine Lux.
Was war das für ein System? Was für ein Prozessor?
Der war nicht ganz so schnell, der hat 2x 1, 6 GHz gehabt.
Was für einen Prozessor? Wie hieß dieser Prozessor? Irgendwas, das sind so... Es spielt schon eine Rolle, weil neuere Intel-Generationen die gängigen AES-Crypto-Operationen schon im Prozessor drin haben. Was diesen Rechenaufwand sehr stark verringert. Wenn der Prozessor etwas älter ist und das nicht mitmacht, dann hast du auch wirklich Last auf der CPU, weil du die ganze Zeit am Fair- und Endschlüsseln bist beim Schreiben auf die Festplatte. Und ab dem modernen i5-Prozessor hast du halt das AES Instruction Set im Prozessor drin. Und der macht das halt einfach...
Was? Die Frage war doch...
Da spürst du halt keinen Unterschied.
Was war eigentlich deine Frage, Max? Warum ist es langsam geworden?
Ich hab das mal probiert und ich wollte wissen, warum war das so langsam? Und ihr meint einfach, weil ich den falschen Prozessor hab.
Nicht den falschen, sondern einen, der mit diesen Operationen offensichtlich stark gefordert war.
Ich weiß nicht. Eigentlich ist AIS auch so schon schnell genug, dass wenn sie da nicht irgendwas in der Implementierung falsch gemacht haben, kann ich mir eigentlich heutzutage mit Prozessoren dienen, die jünger als 10 Jahre sind, sollte das keinen... Das geht im Rauschen der Zeit, die man braucht, um die Daten von der Festplatte zu laden, unter. AIS ist eigentlich echt schnell und...
Im Zweifel lag es tatsächlich daran, dass du da NCFS verwendet hast und nicht Lux.
Ich glaub, das ist auch schon wieder ein bisschen zu detailliert jetzt. Also ich kann eigentlich aus eigener Erfahrung auch sagen, dass Festplattenverschlüsselung anzumachen seit, keine Ahnung, das ist die letzten 5 Jahre sein, keinen ernstzunehmenden Impact mehr hat auf dein System. Wenn du dort einfach nur Häkchen anmachst, dann sollte das gehen.
Oh gut, dann probier's halt irgendwann noch aus. Irgendwann krieg ich's hin.
Genau, dann fang ich mit dem halbwegs aktuellen Rechner an. Max, viel Spaß. Das ist übrigens eine ganz wichtige Sache. Klar ist das so ein bisschen nervig. Und klar, wenn man andere Leute davon überzeugen will, dann sollte es einfach so funktionieren. Aber man kann auch einfach mal so ein bisschen rumspielen, ausprobieren. Auch dazu wollen wir heute hier ermutigen. Ich möchte jetzt gerne noch den letzten Punkt bei den Eltern ansprechen. Und das ist, das hat ja mittlerweile jeder so ein Smartphone in der Tasche. Und da ist dann WhatsApp drauf. Und dann rollen alle mit den Augen, weil WhatsApp, oh Gott, das ist doch und so weiter und so fort. Da gibt es ja oder gibt es da auch Möglichkeiten, über Smartphone sicher mit so einem Messenger umzugehen? Also kann ich iMessage nehmen? Kann ich SMS nehmen? Kann ich halt WhatsApp vielleicht doch nehmen?
Na ja, erklären wir vielleicht mal, wo bei WhatsApp das Problem liegt.
WhatsApp hat eine sehr freigiebige Policy, mit deinen Kontakten umzugehen. Das ist auf der einen Seite toll.
Und die andere Seite, das funktioniert erst mal dadurch, dass es überhaupt mal dein komplettes Adressbuch, wenn diesen WhatsApp-Dienst hochlädt, um zu gucken, wer aus deinen Freunden, also die gucken sich deine ganzen Telefonnummern an, die du da hast, um zu gucken, wer von deinen Freunden auch WhatsApp hat.
Das ist natürlich dann total bequem, weil sich dadurch automatisch so ein soziales Netzwerk herausbildet von den Leuten, die da mitspielen, wird dir dann auch gleich vorgeschlagen, mit wem du dann irgendwie noch da schnacken können möchtest. Das Problem dabei ist, dass wenn du nicht selber den Schlüssel austauschst, muss es jemand für dich tun, wenn sie überhaupt verschlüsseln würden, was sie in den ersten Versionen auch überhaupt gar nicht gemacht haben. Und trotzdem bieten sie dir keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung an, weil du ja nie mit dem anderen Ende den Schlüssel ausgetauscht hast. Also ein generelles Problem bei Messengern, bei denen du dir über den Austausch des Schlüssels keine Gedanken machst, ist, dass es jemand anders für dich tut, dem du dann generell vertrauen musst. Wenn das ein Vi-Message ist von Apple, heißt das, dass du Apple vertrauen musst, dass der Schlüssel, der dort auf beide Geräte getan wird, wenn es eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ist, wirklich niemand außer dir und deinem Gegenüber und Apple und dem Geheimdienst und vielleicht noch die Mitarbeitern dort erkennt. Und für alles, was du wirklich Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsseln möchtest, musst du dir Gedanken darüber machen, wie der Schlüssel ausgetauscht wird.
Bei WhatsApp wissen auch die Firmen, was es ist. Gibt es da eine Runde von neuen Messenger, die versprechen, das besser zu machen?
Ich würde gerne noch mal vorher, du hast ja SMS noch erwähnt, SMS hat unterwegs mehr als genug Probleme, ging bis vor noch gar nicht allzu ferner Zeit, komplett unverschlüsselt über die Funkschnittstelle. Das heißt, dass ganz normale SMS schon mitgelesen werden konnten bis vor 5 Jahren, wenn du einfach nur einen Rechner aufgeklappt hast, der das GSM-Protokoll konnte. Die Verschlüsselung, die dort standardmäßig an ist, um Sprache zu verschlüsseln, wurde bei vielen Betreibern für SMS gar nicht mit angemacht. Danach hast du das Problem, dass eine SMS, wenn sie dann erstmal beim Betreiber ist, kommt sie dann zum nächsten Betreiber. Auf der anderen Seite wird sie auch genauso unverschlüsselt wieder aufs andere Telefon runtergefunkt und kann dort eigentlich an jeder der Stelle da mitgelesen werden. Also SMS ist schon mal wie noch einen deutlichen Zacken leichter einzusehen als alles, was du dir jetzt obendrauf auf deinem Betriebssystem, wo du dir ein bisschen Crypto ausdenkst.
Okay, jetzt gibt es sozusagen eine Runde neuer Messenger. Für mich zumindest war der Anfang war Threemer, Schweizer Firma, die jetzt so ein Ding rausbringt, wo sie sagen, okay, hier, das ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Nicht mal wir wissen, was in den Nachrichten drin steht und wir werfen die auch weg, wenn sie ausgeliefert wurden. Dann gibt es jetzt zu sagen, hat der Typ, der bei Pirate Begins viel mitgemacht hat, der Peter Sunde heißt er, der hat jetzt Hemmles angekündigt, Dienst, der so ähnlich funktionieren soll. Dann gibt es noch so Berliner, die jetzt Hocker XO an den Start gebracht haben. Auch so ein Dienst, also auch so ein Smartphone Messenger, der, wo es auch eine schöne, also was heißt ich, schöne, aber immerhin eine Erklärung gibt, welche Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen sie da benutzen. Sind das jetzt alles Dienste, wo man sagen kann, okay, die funktionieren dann oder ist das auch so, naja, hm?
Definiere doch mal funktionieren.
Die versprechen Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung.
Sie, also wenn sie Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung versprechen und den Source Code offenlegen, dann kann man sich das angucken. Dann kann man sagen, ja, sie haben dort einen der Algorithmen benutzt, die im Allgemeinen als sicher achtet werden von der kryptografischen Community und sie haben keine Fehler gemacht dabei den Zufall auszuwürfen, sie haben keine Fehler dabei gemacht, zu überprüfen, ob der Schlüssel, den du mit deinem Gegenüber austauschst, wirklich derselbe ist, auch auf beiden Seiten. Und wenn das alles gegeben ist, was bei Freema zum Beispiel nicht gegeben ist, was auch bei Hemmles nach aktuellem Stand nicht gegeben sein wird.
Weil den gibt's auch noch gar nicht.
Also gerade gibt es von Hemmles nur eine schöne Webseite, die so aussieht wie, keine Ahnung, abgeschleckt. Wo sie wahrscheinlich eher mit dem Namen von Peter Sunde hausieren gehen wollen und mit einem smoothen Interface, um diesen Messenger ins Volk zu bringen. Da würde ich grundsätzlich gar nichts empfehlen. Es ist halt dann immer schon ein bisschen besser als nichts, aber du sollst dich am Ende nicht sicher fühlen deswegen. Du kannst da irgendwie schon noch mehr Rauschen erzeugen, aber dich komplett darauf zu verlassen, dass du da jetzt Staatsgeheimnisse darüber austauschen kannst, wird ich ohne dass der Quellcode offen ist natürlich nicht.
Das ist bei so was wie einem Mobiltelefon eh illusorisch zu glauben, dass man da ja auch noch einen Ansatz von Sicherheit hat.
Ja gut, wir müssen den Hörern aber noch irgendwas mitgeben, was sie vielleicht nehmen können. Also bei diesem Threemer habe ich doch das eigentlich so verstanden, dass sie zumindest in der Software vorgesehen haben, dass du einen direkten Vergleich deiner Schlüssel machst und das dann auch mit so einer Art Trust-Level für den Key dir wiedergeben. Ja, dass sie sagen, wenn du wirklich jetzt mit eigenen Augen...
Lass mal die Hörer nicht im Regen stehen. Also Trust-Level für den Key. Du musst, wenn du... Lass uns mal dieses ganze PKI-Problem jetzt angehen. Schlüssel zu verteilen auf die Endgeräte ist kein leichtes Problem. Es hat ziemlich viel mit Vertrauen zu tun und es gibt Möglichkeiten dafür zu sorgen, dass du mit einer zentralen Instanz, die für dich die Autorität ist, dann einfach bestimmt, der Schlüssel gehört jetzt zu dieser Person. Das ist jetzt so. In größeren Firmen ist es üblicherweise so, dass dort ein Standard namens SMIME benutzt wird, um dafür zu sorgen, dass es eine zentrale Instanz gibt, die für alle Mitarbeiter den Schlüssel verwaltet und die dann auf die Telefone oder Computer oder Endgeräte drauf tut. Und dann ist es einfach so, du musst aber...
Also es geht um das Problem, ich schreibe Erdgeist eine Nachricht, ich nutze einen Schlüssel, um diese Nachricht zu verschlüsseln. Ich möchte aber, ich kann aber nicht wissen, dass dieser Schlüssel jetzt auch derjenige ist, den Erdgeist und nur Erdgeist entschlüsseln kann.
So, das heißt also bei der Firma, die dieses SMIME benutzt, geht quasi mein Rechner zum zentralen Firmserver und fragt so, du, ich will an den Typen Erdgeist aus der Abteilung PR mal irgendwie was schreiben, gib mir mal den Schlüssel. Dann wird der sozusagen ausgeliefert, mein Mailprogramm.
Du musst erstmal nur deiner zentralen Instanz, also du brauchst am Ende nur einen einzigen Schlüssel, nämlich den von der zentralen Instanz, der du vertrauen kannst. Das ist dann nämlich dieser Server, der diese ganzen anderen Schlüssel verwaltet. Und solange ich dort irgendwo einen Ankerpunkt habe, wo ich einen Schlüssel austauschen muss im Vorfeld, nämlich den von meinem zentralen Server, solange bin ich dann sicher in meinem Firmenetzwerk, ich kann dem vertrauen und benutze aber nur für die interne Kommunikation in der Firma diesen Schlüssel.
Aber das ist doch dann bei solchen Sachen wie 3MAR genauso. Da gibt es dann den zentralen Anbieter, also die Firma, die den Messenger auf den Markt bringt. Und dann hol ich mir diesen Zentral, also dann kommuniziere ich da mit meinem vertrauenswürdigen Einstiegspunkt und kriege dann die Schlüssel von dem.
Genau, und jetzt kommt das Problem, dieser Punkt, die könnten ja jetzt dir auch etwas Falsches sagen. Weil du vertraust den ja. Das heißt, du vertraust 3MAR. Und wenn die sich jetzt entscheiden oder ins Ohr geflüstert bekommen, du der Erdgeist, wenn der nächste Mal dem Linus was schreibt, dann gib dem mal einen anderen Schlüssel. Und dann setzen wir uns in der Mitte hin, kriegen die Nachricht, die der Erdgeist schickt, entschlüsseln sie, verschlüsseln sie erneut und dann mit dem Schlüssel, den der Linus lesen kann, und senden sie an ihn.
Vielleicht sollten wir vorher nochmal erklären, warum das so ein Problem ist, solche Schlüssel einfach untereinander auszutauschen. Ich sag dir jetzt mal kurz, am Telefon oder im Real lieben vielen Zahlen, die schreibst du dir auf und das ist mein Schlüssel, so funktioniert das leider nicht. So ein Schlüssel ist üblicherweise echt lang und irgendwie so lang, dass dir beim Abschreiben ganz sicher Fehler passieren werden. Dass du also für den Transfer des Schlüssels schon noch andere elektronische oder optische Möglichkeiten brauchst, wie zum Beispiel ein QR-Code oder irgendwas, wo du effizient einen Schlüssel transportieren kannst, ohne dass es jemand mitliest. Also einen Schlüssel zum Beispiel in einer unverschlüsselten E-Mail im Vorfeld zu schicken. So, hier ist mein privater Key, schick mal bitte was. Funktioniert halt genauso wenig. Jaja, nee. Hier ist mein privater Key, damit wir einen symmetrischen...
Ich muss an der Stelle mal unterbrechen, weil immer Public Key und Private Key...
Nee, halt.
Wir kommen jetzt gerade von Hölzchen auf Stöckchen und ich fühlte, so würde das nicht funktionieren. Das Problem, das wir gerade haben, und darauf möchte ich jetzt mal zurückführen, sind Smartphone-Messengers. Das Problem, was ihr gesagt habt, ist, dass man die Verschlüsselung sozusagen, dass nicht richtig nachweisbar ist, ob diese Verschlüsselung wirklich nur zwischen Sender und Empfänger funktioniert. Weil zwei Punkte. Einerseits ist die Software nicht open source, das heißt, niemand kann genau wissen, was die da machen. Andererseits muss ich mich bei dem Austausch der Informationen, wie verschlüsselt wird, darauf verlassen, dass der Anbieter, der die Infrastruktur betreibt, nicht sagt, ich machs wie bei dir E-Mail, du schickst mir eine verschlüsselte Nachricht, ich mach die auf, verschlüssel die nochmal, schick die dann an deinen Kumpel. Das heißt, wir haben bei all diesen Smartphone-Messengern das Problem, dass es ein bisschen besser ist, als gar nichts zu verschlüsseln. Also quasi wie bei Skype, quasi wie bei HTTPS Everywhere. Ich muss mich darauf verlassen, dass der Anbieter vertrauenswürdig ist. Gegenüber vierten heißt es ja also, ich hab mich den Empfänger und als dritte Partei noch den Anbieter. Aber gegenüber vierten ist es sicher möglicherweise.
Sicher genug.
Solange, bis es sich mal jemand nachweist oder sagt, es ist erst mal sicher genug.
Es gibt auch mal so die Rahmenbedingungen. Auf einem Mobiltelefon hast du einfach andere Rahmenbedingungen als auf anderen Geräten. Da man sich da eh grundsätzlich darauf verlassen muss, dass da bestimmte Dinge nicht komprometiert sind, die man nicht nachprüfen kann. Also du kannst ein Mobiltelefon nicht ansehen, ob da jetzt, also es gibt gar keine Mittel zu sehen, ob man dem Gerät überhaupt noch vertrauen kann oder ob da Dinge drauf sind, die die Integrität des Geräts komprometieren.
Du willst sagen, dass da wieder Trojaner drauf sind, die die Informationen auch so ausleiten.
Ja, aber das weiß ich ja beim Rechner auch nicht. Also sagen, dass jetzt noch mal zusätzlich Fass aufzumachen, sprengt glaube ich den Rahmen des normalen Users.
Ja, noch mal eine Ecke einfacher als bei einem Mobiltelefon.
So, aber lass uns mal irgendwie einfach jetzt weiter bei den, also der CTC empfiehlt halt generell keine Produkte. Wir sagen, worauf man gucken sollte, wenn man dieses Produkt benutzen möchte, was die Kriterien sind, die wir persönlich dafür anlegen und diese Messenger erfüllen diese Kriterien gerade nicht. Aber man kann sagen, wenn man sie benutzt, dann macht man es schon mal ein bisschen sicherer als vorher. Und viele von den Ansätzen sind zumindest dazu geeignet, dass es auch wirklich passiert. Also sie sind schick und benutzbar genug, als dass sie...
Elternkompatibel.
Elternkompatibel besser als, oder schicker als WhatsApp. Und dann am Ende wird zumindest ein Schlüssel ausgetauscht und für 99% der Fälle ist es dann auch gut genug. Man muss aber auch wissen, dass es die 100%ige Sicherheit natürlich da nicht gibt an der Stelle.
Aber, und das nehme ich mit zu sagen, also ich finde einen der Vorteile bei diesen ganzen Angeboten ist ja, dass Sicherheit überhaupt zum Konzept einer Kommunikationssoftware gehört. Das ist ja nicht selbstverständlich sozusagen. Und die Leute haben zumindest sich Gedanken drum gemacht. Und das andere halt, wie gesagt, besser als nicht. Und es ist tatsächlich Elternkompatibel. So, jetzt haben wir noch einen Punkt auf der Elternliste, der steht nicht Google nehmen.
Man kann ja seinen Eltern in den Browser eine andere Suchmaschine einstellen. Also mir persönlich ist wichtig, dass wenn man seine private Kommunikation vor den Augen ausländischer Geheimdienste verbergen möchte, dann kann man natürlich auch wieder bei einer US-amerikanischen Firma vorbeigehen und ihr direkt das halbe Leben in der Form seiner Suchanfragen an diese Suchmaschine präsentieren. Und man kann sich natürlich auch dann mal bewusst machen, dass was dort dann an Informationen zusammengesammelt wird, auch ziemlich viel über dich und dein Leben und auch das Leben deiner Eltern aussagt, sodass sich vorher Gedanken zu machen, welche Suchmaschine man benutzt und welche Suchmaschine man seine Eltern benutzen lassen möchte und ihnen das einzustellen, das ist einfach nur ein Klick in den Einstellungen bei den meisten Browsern, benutzen sie eine andere Suchmaschine, lass es Daktaco sein, lass es Bing sein. Was ist natürlich...
Bing?
Wait, die Microsoft-Suchmaschine?
Ja, ich würde die nicht empfehlen, aber man soll sich halt bewusst seine Entscheidung treffen, welche von den Firmen man da sein innerstes dort in Form der Suchanfragen offenbaren möchte.
Okay, du hast ja jetzt gerade gesagt, der CCC empfiehlt keine Produkte. Darf ich dir vielleicht trotzdem die Frage stellen, welche Suchmaschine du persönlich benutzt?
Mehrere, also neben Daktaco, Google natürlich.
Aber sozusagen nicht nur eine, sondern du bist verschiedener. Welche hast du deinen Eltern eingestellt?
Meine Eltern benutzen Web.de eher als Suchmaschine.
Man kann es nicht immer ändern.
Meine riefen kürzlich an, dass ihr das Alter wisst, da ich nicht mehr ginge. Ich hab aber auch schon echt nichts mehr an dem Computer gemacht.
So, jetzt haben wir die Elternliste abgehakt. Aber wir haben jetzt eigentlich noch zwei Punkte, aber nur noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Das kann ja heiter werden.
Uff, na, ich find ja dieses PKI-Problem immer noch, also diese öffentliche Schlüsselinfrastruktur, was der alternative Ansatz ist, wenn du keine zentrale Instanz hast, die die Keys verteilt, dann brauchst du irgendeine Art von Vertrauen, wo du mal einen Anker brauchst, um dafür zu sorgen, dass du dir die Schlüssel deines Gegenübers besorgen kannst.
Okay, sagst du mir gerade, wir erklären gleich E-Mail-Verschlüsselung?
Wir erklären gleich Verschlüsselung, die gerade größtenteils für E-Mails benutzt wird, aber auch in anderen Chat-Klines zum Beispiel auch mit benutzt wird.
Machen wir gleich. Vorher Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Und nun zu einer genialen Band, die aus Frankreich kommt, aber auf Englisch singt, ein knappes sachliches Statement von unserem Fritz Franzosen. Donnerstag, 21. November. Phoenix live in der Kolumbiale. Mit neuem Sound und neuem Halbblut.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Nachricht mit Golo Schmid.
Auch nach der heutigen Sitzung des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums sieht die Opposition in der Ausspäher-Affäre weiter Aufklärungsbedarf. Nach der dreistündigen Sitzung sagte der Ausschussvorsitzende und SPD-Politiker Oppermann, es sei immer noch nicht klar, wann und was die Bundesregierung über die Überwachungsaktion des US-Geheimdienstes NSA gewusst habe. Kanzleramtschef Pofalla wies den Vorwurf zurück, deutsche Bürger seien umfangreich durch den amerikanischen Geheimdienst ausgespäht worden. Der Datenschutz in Deutschland sei eingehalten worden, sagte Pofalla. Laut Oppermann will das Gremium nun im August zu zwei weiteren Sitzungen zusammenkommen. Das schwere Zugunglück in Spanien ist offenbar durch eine überhöhte Geschwindigkeit des Zuges verursacht worden. Der Lokführer soll Medienberichten zufolge eingeräumt haben, dass er mit 190 kmh unterwegs war, als der Schnellzug in der Nähe von Santiago de Compostela entgleiste. Zulässig war dort nur Tempo 80. Nach Angaben der staatlichen Bahngesellschaft gab es an dem Zug auch kein technisches Problem. Mindestens 80 Menschen kamen bei dem Umfall ums Leben, mindestens 180 wurden verletzt. Ministerpräsident Rajoy ordnete drei Tage Staatstrauer an. Ein dreitägiger Streik der Schleusenwärter hat den Schiffsverkehr auf der Spree in Berlin weitgehend lahmgelegt. Lediglich Ausflugsdampfer können noch auf dem kurzen Flussabschnitt zwischen Mühlendammschleuse in Berlin-Mitte und der Schleuse Charlottenburg pendeln. Die besonders bei Touristen beliebten Stadtrundfahrten wurden ganz eingestellt. Die Berliner Reederei befürchtet Umsatzeinbußen von etwa 30.000 Euro pro Tag. Auch in Brandenburg ist der Schiffsverkehr erheblich beeinträchtigt. Deutschland trifft im Finale der Frauenfußball-EM auf Norwegen. Im zweiten Halbfinalspiel gewann Norwegen gegen Dänemark mit 4 zu 2 nach Elfmeterschießen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Marzahn 20 zählen dort auf 24 Grad. Prenzlau 20, Ludwigsfelde, Prenzlau und Küritz jeweils 21 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es meist trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 18 bis 14 Grad runter. Morgen ist es dann überwiegend trocken bei Höchstwerten von knapp über 30 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111 Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Schulzendorfer Straße und Weidmannsluster Damm-Hermsdorfer Damm ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Und A115A, wo es Richtung Berlin am Dreieckfunkturm ist, ist die Tangente in Richtung A100 bis 5 Uhr gesperrt. Zum Verkehr in Brandenburg A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Wollin und Brandenburg an der Havel gibt es Behinderungen durch einen kaputten Laster. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf blockiert ein kaputtes Auto die rechte Spur in Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Und A113 Zubringer Schönefeld zwischen Dreieck-Weitersdorf und Schönefelder Kreuz sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Straße. Ansonsten rollt es euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio eben, Blue Moon und wollen noch ein paar Dinge erklären, die man zur Verschlüsselung möglicherweise benutzen kann. Wir haben jetzt ganz schön viel Zeit damit verbracht zu erklären, was man seinen Eltern beibringen kann als Verschlüsselung zu nutzen. Und da ging es um darum verschüsselte Webbrowsing, um Smartphone Messenger und um Festplattenverschlüsselung und darum, warum Skype eigentlich gar nicht so geil ist, aber manchmal besser als nichts. So, zu Gast sind immer noch Erdgeisten, Nibler und Linus. Und wir wollen jetzt nochmal, oder ihr wollt nochmal erklären, wie das ist mit diesem ganzen Verschlüsselungsding, dass man unter PGPG, asymmetrische Verschlüsselung, E-Mail Verschlüsselung und etc.
PGP ist ein standardisiertes Protokoll, was sich Phil Zimmerman vor so 15 Jahren ausgedacht hat, in dem es darum geht, verschlüsselte Nachrichten in einem standardisierten Format auszutauschen. Er hat dabei gleich noch eine Infrastruktur erfunden, in der man seine öffentlichen Schlüssel der Welt verteilen kann. Da ist jetzt spannend zu wissen, dass für diese PGP-Verschlüsselung, während man sich seinen eigenen Schlüssel ausdenkt, denkt man sich in Wirklichkeit zwei Schlüssel aus. Das eine ist ein Geheimerschlüssel, den behält man für sich, und ein öffentlicher Schlüssel, den hängt man überall hin und verteilt. Und da gibt es Betreiber von Servern weltweit, die sich auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Schlüssel überall von allen runtergeladen werden können. Und dass man, wenn man nach einer E-Mail-Adresse sucht zum Beispiel, diesen Schlüssel dann wieder findet und sich runterladen und dann innerhalb von PGP benutzen kann. PGP selber wird aktuell größtenteils für die Verschlüsselung von E-Mails benutzt, aber ist generell nicht darauf limitiert. Kann zur Verschlüsselung von Dateien auf deinem Computer benutzt werden, kann zum Verschlüsseln von Chatnachrichten benutzt werden.
Du kannst natürlich auch Podcasts.
Man kann damit auch Postkarten verschlüsseln. Die Idee dabei ist, dass, wenn du deinen öffentlichen Schlüssel jemandem zur Verfügung stellst, über irgendeine Art und Weise, dann kann der diesen Schlüssel mit deinem Schlüssel vergleichen, indem ihr ein kleines Exerpt damit... Na, da fällt eine Zahlenkolonie raus. Das sind so sechsten Hexadezimalzahlen. Und die kannst du vergleichen. Und das Tolle ist, wenn du diese Zahlen überprüft hast, dass die schon dieselben sind, wie was ich beim Erzeugen des Schlüssels auch als Fingerabdruck dort hab rausfallen sehen, dann ist man sich schon ziemlich sicher, dass du und ich jetzt denselben Schlüssel haben.
Also, ich lade mir aus dem Internet eine riesige Zahlenkolonne runter. Die heißt Public Keyblock. Und damit kann ich zu der PGP-Software auf meinem Rechner gehen, diese große Zahlenkolonne reinwerfen und sagen, gib mir mal bitte den Fingerabdruck dieser großen Zahlenkolonne. Dann kommt diese sechstenstellige Zahl drauf. Dann ruf ich dich an und sage, du, ich habe im Internet einen öffentlichen Schlüssel gefunden und habe den bei mir bei PGP reingeworfen. Es hat gesagt, es sind diese sechsten Zahlen. Dann sagst du, stimmt.
Genau, dann musst du nur noch der Stimme am Telefon vertrauen. Wir sind gerade schon im Aluhut-Modus.
Warum braucht man da einen öffentlichen und privaten Schlüssel? Was machen diese beiden Schlüssel?
Das Verfahren beruht darauf, dass man eben nicht nur einen Schlüssel hat, mit dem man Dinge fernentschlüsselt, sondern dass das entkoppelt ist. Also dass man zwei Schlüssel hat. Dinge, die man mit dem einen Schlüssel verschlüsselt, kann man nur mit dem anderen Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel von mir etwas verschlüsselst, dann kann ich das nur noch mit meinem privaten Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Umgekehrt, wenn ich Dinge mit meinem privaten Schlüssel verschlüssel, dann kannst du die nur mit meinem öffentlichen Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Deswegen macht man das immer doppelt. Man verschlüsselt mit seinem privaten Schlüssel und mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel der Person, mit dem man sprechen möchte. Dann braucht er nämlich zwei Dinge, seinen privaten Schlüssel, meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel. Mit meinem öffentlichen Schlüssel stellt er sicher, ja, das kommt wirklich von dem. Und mit dem privaten Schlüssel von sich selbst kann nur er diese Nachricht entschlüsseln.
Das klingt so einfach. Hat es jemand nicht verstanden? Hat es jemand nicht verstanden? Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Weil ihr müsst wissen, asrimetische Verschlüsseln zu erklären, das ist so eine Sache, an der verzweifeln Leute, die das gerne machen. Es gibt ganz viele Analogien, die man benutzen kann. Wer war das von euch mit den Schnappschlossern? Ja, hier, mach mal.
Mach mal das Schnappschloss. Um es einfach zu erklären. Das große geistige Problem für alle, die das erste Mal PGP benutzen, ist, welchen Key gebe ich denn jetzt jemandem? Dann liegt da ein Private Key und ein Public Key. Man denkt sich, ich möchte doch private kommunizieren, also schicke ich den Private Key an meinen Freund. In dem Moment kann man dann dieses Key Pair wegwerfen und darf es nie wieder benutzen. Die Analogie, die ich immer zum Einstieg nehme, ist, der Public Key ist ein... Ein...
Schnappschloss?
Schnappschloss, so ein Bügel-Schloss. Und der Private Key ist der Schlüssel dazu. Und dieses Schnappschloss, das verteile ich an alle meine Freunde und gebe es ihnen und die haben es alle dabei. Und jeder kann es haben, es ist auch nicht geheim. Deswegen wird es ja auf öffentlichen Servern, liegt es ja zum Abruf für jedermann. Und der geheime Schlüssel, mit dem ich das dann entschlüsseln kann, den habe nur ich.
Also den Schlüssel, der in das Schnappschloss reinpasst.
Genau, so verrückt.
Das sind jetzt zwei verschiedene Arten. Und ich war gerade sehr fasziniert davon, dass für mich zumindest Nibblers Erklärung verständlicher war als die mit dem Schnappschloss. Das fand ich witzig, weil wir haben vorher gestritten, ob jetzt die abstrakte Erklärung... Na ja, schon, aber es hinkt natürlich. Klar, ich kann es mit dem Schnappschloss vorstellen, aber jetzt sich vorzustellen, an jeder Stadt in der Welt hängen 50.000 Schnappschlösser, die meinen Namen haben. Klar, es ist eine einfache Erklärung, aber egal.
Wenn ich es nicht mit der Erklärung hatte, wäre es ein kleines sachlichen Fehler. Eine gute Analogie ist wie ein diagonaler Frosch.
Äh, gut. Also wer es noch nicht verstanden hat, warum es dort zwei Schlüsselteile gibt, der kann jetzt bitte anrufen. 0371 77 97 10 0. Wir haben nur noch bis 12 Zeit, aber ich würde gerne sicherstellen, dass das diesmal funktioniert hat.
Soll ich die Antwort schon mal geben? Es gibt die zwei Schlüsselteile, weil wenn es keine zwei gäbe, dann wäre das einzige Geheimnis, was die beiden Parteien teilen, das Passwort. Und das kann ich ja nun mal nicht offen irgendwo hinschreiben.
Das stimmt.
Wir haben jetzt noch die Art und Weise, die Nibble erklärt hat, wie man da seinen geheimen Schlüssel benutzen kann, um etwas zu verschlüsseln, da fällt dann eine Signatur raus. Das heißt, du verschlüsselst damit Teile deiner Nachricht und die andere Seite kann dadurch ja überprüfen, ob du das wirklich mit deinem geheimen Schlüssel verschlüsselt hast. Und du kannst diese Eigenschaft jetzt auch noch benutzen, um an Schlüsselsignaturen heranzuhängen. Das heißt, du findest im Internet den Schlüssel von Markus Richter. Du lädst diesen Schlüssel runter und du sagst jetzt, ich hab das überprüft, ich hab den Fingerprint mit ihm am Telefon ausgetauscht, das ist der wirklich. Und ich hänge da mal, damit alle das überprüfen können, eine Signatur auch wieder ran und sage, das stimmt so, verschlüssel das mit meinem geheimen Schlüssel und lade das wieder hoch. Alle anderen, die meinen privaten Schlüssel haben, mein öffentlichen Schlüssel haben und dem schon vertrauen, können einfach nachgucken, na ja, ich kenn jetzt zwar den Erdgeist, aber den Markus seinen Schlüssel nicht. Und ich hab irgendwie den Erdgeist seinen Schlüssel überprüft, ob der übereinstimmt. Und der Erdgeist mit seinem öffentlichen Schlüssel hat jetzt für mich nachprüfbar auch die Signatur an den öffentlichen Schlüssel von Markus rangehängt. Und habe damit eine transitive Vertrauensbeziehung aufgebaut. Also ich muss einfach nur entlang der gesamten Kette eigentlich allen vertrauen. Aber wenn ich den vertraue, dann ist für mich die Wahrscheinlichkeit schon hoch genug.
Gegenfrage, und damit komm ich jetzt zum Anfang der Sendung. Das Schlimme an der Überwachung sind ja die Metadaten. Wenn jetzt alle Leute ihre Schlüssel untereinander unterschreiben, habe ich nicht dann sozusagen genauso die Abbildung eines sozialen Netzwerkes in diese Schlüsselinfrastruktur gegossen, die dann jeder nachvollziehen kann?
Das ist korrekt.
Dann würde ich ja lieber anrufen.
Das hat zwei Effekte. Der erste ist, dass einige bestimmte Schlüssel eben nicht auf Key Server werfen. Und den anderen Effekt, dass es so einen kleinen Kult natürlich gibt, von wem der eigene Key schon alles signiert ist. Und dass man sich dann natürlich auch freuen kann, wenn man eine Signatur von einer bestimmten Person hat und damit angeben kann.
Dafür wurden dann früher so Key Signing Parties organisiert, dass da einfach dann der Fakt, dass man durch Zufall bei dieser Key Signing Party dabei gewesen ist, ist halt nicht ganz so doll so schlimm wie...
Also quasi das Problem an diesem System ist eigentlich, dass die Leute dazu tendieren, nur die Schlüssel zu signieren, die von Leuten, die sie persönlich kennen.
Das Schlimme ist, dass Leute auch anfangen, auf einmal Schlüssel zu signieren von Leuten, die sie nicht kennen.
Das ist das Problem tatsächlich mit diesem Web of Trust, dass man halt nur bis zu einer bestimmten Tiefe in diesem Netz Leuten vertrauen kann. Ich vertraue es vielleicht Erdgeist und vielleicht dir, Markus, aber ich bin mir halt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob alle Leute, denen ihr so vertraut, ob die...
Okay, jetzt haben wir grob mal erklärt, was an diesem PKI, an dieser Public Key Infrastruktur, also dieser öffentlichen Schlüsselinfrastruktur das Problem ist. Aber dieses PGP ist jetzt auch alt und abgehangen genug, dass man es eigentlich empfehlen kann. Und wir würden jetzt auch das gerne empfehlen, zum Beispiel zum Verschlüsseln von E-Mails. Und da gibt es, wenn du jemanden hast, der ein Windows zum Beispiel installiert hat, gibt es prima fertige Installer, die heißen PGP for Win. Klickst da einmal drauf, bringt alles mit, was er braucht. PGP und ein Plug-in für Thunderbird. Es gibt sogar fertige, wie heißt das, Mobile Apps, ein fertiges Paket, was du auf deinem USB-Stick drauf tun kannst, wo schon Thunderbird mit diesem Enig-Mail und PGP fertiggebundelt ist, die Scripts alle richtig aufgesetzt sind, dass er die Schlüssel auch findet. Jetzt hab ich genau vergessen, wie der heißt, aber das werden wir dann in den Show-Notz eintragen. Und mit dem kannst du einfach, wenn deine Eltern schon Thunderbird zum E-Mail lesen benutzen, dann kannst du dieses Enig-Mail dort anmachen und kannst schon mal die Schlüssel einfach runterladen, überprüfen und danach einstellen, dass er eigentlich immer verschlüsseln soll und hast danach eigentlich schon Crypto in E-Mails bei den Eltern zumindest für dich angemacht.
aus Rheiningen-Dorf, der will PDP nochmal anders erklären. Hallo Stefan.
Hallo.
Schieß los.
Ja, also ich hab das so gedacht, ist es nicht so, dass wenn sozusagen, wir nehmen mal als Einschlüsse, wer einen Stift, also die Farbe des Stiftes, dem schreibe und das andere wäre das Papier, also die Farbe des Papiers sozusagen. Und dann wäre das ja so, dass man nicht nur an der, dass man nicht an der Schriftfarbe und an der Papierfarbe erkennen könnte. Und da hab ich es so verstanden, dass ich die Zettel verteile und ich von einem sozusagen die anderen Leute drauf verschreiben kann. Und wenn irgendjemand mit Rot schreibt zum Beispiel, weiß ich wer das ist. Und er schickt mir dann sozusagen ein Zettel mit meiner Farbe und seiner Stiftfarbe.
Stefan, nein. Also ganz ehrlich, nein. Ich weiß ja, warum es geht, aber ich habe selbst da nicht verstanden, wie du das meinst.
Ich verstehe, was du sagen möchtest, aber der Text ist ja immer noch, also den kann man ja trotzdem lesen.
Bei dir fehlt die Verschlüsselung. Aber es ist eine schöne Analogie.
Für was?
Aber eben halt nicht für PCP.
Ja, Stefan, sorry. Aber vielen Dank, dass du es versucht hast.
Was wir vielleicht auch ansprechen sollten, ist Instant Messaging. Kann man, wenn man Java nutzt, eine Verschlüsselungstechnologie nennen. Diese nennt sich OTR, also Off the Record Messaging. Das hat ein paar andere Eigenschaften. Nämlich, dass die Nachrichten, dass im Nachhinein der Schlüssel veröffentlicht wird. Sprich, man nicht mehr nachweisen kann, dass die Nachrichten wirklich von mir gekommen sind. Sie aber auch nicht aufmachen kann, weil der andere, wie läuft das?
Nee, die Idee dabei ist...
Riecht ihr euch gerade selber durcheinander?
Nein, die Idee bei OTR ist, dass man auf beiden Seiten denselben Schlüssel hat und dadurch nie nachweisen kann, dass es wirklich die andere Seite ist, die diese letzte Nachricht geschrieben hat. Man hätte es auch selber schreiben können. Du kannst, wenn du nämlich chatterst und benutzt PGP und signierst deine Nachricht, dann willst du es im Allgemeinen nicht. Wenn ich irgendwie betrunken in meinem Messenger irgendwas reintippe, dann will ich nicht, dass die Gegenseite eine Signatur von mir hat. Und OTR ist einfach nur, dass beide Seiten denselben Schlüssel haben und damit man nicht beweisen kann einem Dritten, dass die Gegenseite etwas geschrieben hat, aber selber nachvollziehen kann, dass dem so ist.
Das hört sich für mich schon sehr aluhutig an, würde ich sagen. Also OTR ist eine Möglichkeit, Chats zu verschlüsseln? Ist etablierter als PGP, was wir gerade erklärt haben, um Chats zu verschlüsseln?
50-50 denke ich mal gerade.
Wo gibt es das? Ich kenne es von OSC. Da gibt es Adium, so ein Instant-Messenger und der hat das sozusagen gleich mit eingebaut.
Wenn man Java, also XMPP, Protokoll verwendet, dann kann der Client das in der Regel selbst oder mit einem Plugin. Also in dem Moment, wo man Java benutzt, muss man einfach mal sich gucken, ob es da für den Client, den man verwendet, ein Plugin gibt und dann einfach benutzen. Das ist nämlich superdoll einfach, das zu verwenden. Man sagt einfach nur mach OTR an, dann sehen beide Seiten, OTR ist an. So und dann ist das schonmal verschlüsselt. Und dann kann man noch darüber hinaus den Fingerprint vergleichen, genauso wie bei BGP und für den, mit dem man sich da unterhält, den Fingerprint auf, habe ich verifiziert. Dann wird das grün und man weiß in Zukunft, dass dazu stimmt.
Ist das dann sozusagen etwas, was man auch seinen Eltern, wenn man es soweit verstanden hat, dass man selber durchsteigt, andunen könnte, und das ist dann besser als Skype?
Problemlos.
OTR ist dann wirklich garantiert Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und auch BGP im Chatprogramm ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, ist aber wieder, wenn man seinen Eltern installiert, dann fragen die, warum Video anrufe nicht funktionieren und Sprachanrufe da drüber nicht. Und dann muss man denen dann irgendwie Mumble installieren und dann...
Man kann auch über XMPP... Ich hab da kürzlich einen XMPP-Klient ausprobiert, der das tatsächlich konnte.
Okay, das ist dann aber schon für fortgeschritten.
Ja, das ist schon für fortgeschritten und ja, meistens geht's damit einher, dass man irgendwie auch noch ein anderes Programm installieren muss, was die dann benutzen, um zu chatten, indem man eigentlich nur selber erreichbar ist. Es ist schon echt schwierig, dann seinen Eltern das mal eben zu installieren.
So, jetzt haben wir sehr viel Zeit damit zugebracht, was ich auch gut fand. Ich will tatsächlich sagen, das wichtigste Thema heute ist tatsächlich auch das, was am einfachsten zu verwenden ist, das, was man schnell vielen Leuten zeigen kann. Ich hoffe, ihr habt so ein bisschen Spaß dran gefunden und möchtet es möglicherweise noch weiter reichen. Falls ihr auch zugehört habt und denkt so, ich hab mich nicht getraut anzurufen, aber ich hab's doch nicht so ganz verstanden, ist dieses Konzept der Cryptoparty, das gibt es tatsächlich und das ist tatsächlich extra dafür gemacht, dass man dahin kommt und fragen kann, wie funktioniert das. Also, könnt ihr gerne machen, Cryptoparty.in ist so eine zentrale Webseite, die sammelt das für alle Städte, wo man sowas machen kann. Ich möchte jetzt hier die letzten paar Minuten, also so fünf ungefähr, nochmal sozusagen für den Aluhut-Modus freigeben.
Na, wir haben erst mal noch entdeckt, dass es eigentlich noch eine viel, viel, viel einfachere Möglichkeit gibt, grundsätzlich Datenverkehr vor den Geheimdiensten zu verstecken, indem nämlich einfach die großen Anbieter von Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur, also die Leute, die da so das Rückgrat des Internets zur Verfügung stellen, die haben da ja auch eigentlich nur sehr rechenmächtige Computer, die über Kabel à la couleur miteinander verbunden sind. Und diese Kabel reichen manchmal von einem Rechenzentrum in der Stadt zum nächsten, manchmal reichen sie in eine ganz andere Stadt, manchmal reichen sie auf einen ganz anderen Kontinenten. Und die Kommunikation darüber ist unverschlüsselt. Das heißt, wenn man mal eine politische Forderung aufstellen sollte, die dazu führt, dass grundsätzlich aller Internetverkehr zwischen den Datenzentren von einem Internetanbieter verschlüsselt ist, dann wäre damit schon mal viel gewonnen. Dann könnten die Geheimdienste nämlich nicht dahergehen und einfach sich auf das Kabel setzen und gucken, was da so durchgeht, sondern müssten sich dann schon sehr intensiv an die ISPs und Anbieter wenden, um dort mal mitlesen zu dürfen.
Das heißt, es limitiert sozusagen den Zugriff in der Form, dass nur der Betreiber selbst und die Dienste in der Erosdiktion, in der der Betreiber zu Hause ist, darauf zugreifen können. Da spart man sich dann nicht, dass man verschlüsselt, aber man weiß ein bisschen mehr, wer da alles reingucken kann. Und das sind halt keine Dienste aus anderen Ländern, die dann sagen, wir haben da mal alle Daten. Dann sagt der BND, das ist toll, dass ihr die habt, die hätten wir dann auch. Sondern das trennt das Ganze halt ein bisschen auf. Aber man kann nicht ein Land einmal alles abschneuchen.
Aber die kooperieren doch ohnehin zusammen. Ich halte das auf dem Layer nicht für adäquat. Da sehe ich jetzt echt wenig Gewinn, wenn man das machen würde. Ja, das ist eine politische Frage. Aber die politische Entscheidung ist inzwischen so weit, dass sie aktiv gezielt kooperieren. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay...
Man kann nicht den Menschen erzählen, sie sollen mal alle schön verschlüsseln. Während die Leute, die dort an den zentralen Knotenpunkten sitzen, wenn die da nicht mal ihre Daten verschlüsseln, dann ist das ein hohles Argument. Also sollen die mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen dafür sorgen, dass man nicht einfach nur auf dem Kabel sitzen muss. Dann grüßen sie halt nicht nur unsere Geheimdienste, sondern auch die, was ist der Standardbeispiel, Chinesen, Iraner, Israelis, die dann gerade mal nicht Freund des Tages sind. Die sollen natürlich auch nicht mitlesen können, wenn man jetzt mal gerade die US-Amerikaner an der Stelle lieb hat.
Also mit der Forderung, dass sie ihre dicken Internetdaten verschlüsseln, ist nicht die Hoffnung, dass das dann tatsächlich nicht abgegriffen werden kann. Aber es macht es dann einfacher, Verantwortlichkeiten aufzuzeigen, wenn so eine Daten mal wieder großflächig irgendwo auftauchen. Wir haben noch einen Anrufer, Lorenz aus Greifswald, der etwas von euch wissen will. Hallo Lorenz.
Mich würde eigentlich interessieren, ob sich da jetzt innerhalb des CCC so ein bisschen die Einstellung ändert. Also dieses so ein bisschen Gebetsmühlenartiges seit 20 Jahren wiederholte. Ja, wir müssen unsere Kommunikation verschlüsseln. Und ich mach das jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei E-Mails gelegentlich, wenn ich entsprechende Kontakte habe. Aber ich meine, es ist ja so, dass die Metadaten ja eigentlich viel interessanter sind. Das ist ja jetzt auch teilweise schon angeklungen. Das ist ja auch nichts Neues.
Das ist ja auch keine neue Erkenntnis.
Und die sind anders interessant. Also natürlich sind auch die Inhaltsdaten immer noch sehr spannender.
Ich glaube, Lorenz hat dir die Frage noch nicht gestellt.
Ja genau, ich möchte jetzt mal wissen, ist es so, dass wir in Zukunft erleben werden, dass der TTC anders lautende Empfehlungen ausgibt als, ja, verschlüsselt bitte was das Zeug hält, sondern eher so in die Richtung überlegt, dass ihr genau, ob ihr überhaupt verschlüsselt.
Oh Gott, das ist das, was du aus der Sendung gerade rausgezogen hast. Nein, eigentlich haben wir gesagt, dass wir gerade versuchen wollten, verschlüsselt selber, was das Zeug hält, aber geht noch daher und sorgt dafür, dass eure Eltern auch verschlüsseln. Und das hier sind gerade die Werkzeuge, die die niedrigst hängenden Früchte sind zum Pflücken, die man als allererstes da mal anschalten soll. Natürlich, alle Leute, die die technische Fähigkeit dazu haben, sollten weiter sämtliche harte Crypto, deren sie herbehaft werden können, benutzen, um ihre Kommunikation zu sichern. Und sollten auch noch dabei aufpassen, dass ihre Metadaten dabei nicht in fremde Hände fallen, indem sie zum Beispiel Toa benutzen.
Also wenn ich das noch mal als Übersetzer versuchen kann, ist es möglicherweise eine Änderung eingetreten, aber eher in der Richtung, dass man annimmt, wir können nicht alle sofort auf den höchsten Bestenstand der Crypto bringen. Deswegen können wir auch mal die Sachen vorstellen, die einfach zu machen sind und die sagen, zwar nicht perfekt, aber ein Schritt auf dem Weg sind. Hilft dir das was, Lorenz?
So, jetzt die Aluhut-Lösung.
Noch eine Minute Aluhut.
Eine Minute Aluhut? Ich hab ja öfter mal, eins meiner Hobbys ist ja Blogger aus dem grad demokratisch bedrohten Freundesland der Welt, sei es irgendwie die arabische Welt oder sei es das Baltikum, denen ich Dinge erzähle, wie sie ihre Rechner schützen können, wie sie ihre Kommunikation schützen können. Und dem hab ich auch erzählt, hier so nimmst du TrueCrypt und hab ihnen besondere Vorschläge gemacht, wie sie dann bei der Passworteingabe aufpassen sollen, dass es inzwischen irgendwie Abstrahlung der Tastatur kann man aufnehmen und man kann mit Teleobjektiven dabei zugucken, wie man das Passwort eingibt. Und so ein ägyptischer Blogger hat mich mit großen Augen angeguckt und gemeint, wenn mein Geheimdienst wissen möchte, was mein Passwort ist, dann bricht er mir die Knie, bis ich es ihm sage. Dann ist der Schutz des Passworts dort eher so sekundär. Und dann hab ich drauf gekommen, aber True Crypt kann auch Hidden Partitions. Du kannst also dafür sorgen, dass dort mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern einfach unterschiedliche Dinge zu sehen sind. Du kannst dir also eine Partition anlegen, wo deine Familienfotos dabei sind, schön noch Gedichte, die du geschrieben hast und deine politische Arbeit einfach nur zu sehen ist, wenn du eine andere Passphrase eingibst. Was also bedeutet, dass du deine Festplattenverschlüsselung so gestalten kannst, dass man am Ende, wenn man dich zwingt, dein Passwort rauszugeben, kannst du ihnen eins geben, kommt sogar was raus, ist aber nicht das, was sie unbedingt sehen wollen.
Versteckt man dann in dieser Fake-Partition, wo man sich mit seinem Fake-Login anmeldet, dann auch so ein bisschen Porn, damit es glaubwürdig wirkt?
Na, was immer deine Festplatte hergibt, ist doch schon mal ein schönes Maß, was nicht auffällig ist.
Okay, gibt es jetzt also nur so Schlagwort-mäßig, gibt es irgendwie noch so eine Sache, wo ihr sagt, so hier, wenn ihr es nochmal wirklich hart wissen wollt, probiert das mal aus? Na ja, also so dieses Aluhut-Ding.
Ja, VPNs größten Platz. Es gibt inzwischen Anbieter, die für 5 Euro im Monat, die erlauben, nicht aus Deutschland mit deiner Internetverbindung zu kommen. Die hatten ja jetzt auch gerade akut auch Probleme. So eine schwedische Firma, die vorher mit The Pirate Bay viel zu tun hatten, weil PayPal und die großen Kreditkartenbetreiber ihnen den Geldhahn abgedreht haben und sie den Service da jetzt nicht weiter finanzieren lassen können.
Also VPNs sind diese, wo man seine Internetverbindung verbirgt quasi.
Das ist halt ein virtuelles privates Netzwerk. Das heißt, da kommt dein Internettraffic plötzlich nicht mehr aus Deutschland von der Telekom, bei dir zu Hause eine DSL-Leitung, sondern aus einem Rechenzentrum in Schweden, die für dich stellvertretend die Pakete ins Internet weiterreichen, was auch ganz praktisch beim YouTube gucken ist, weil du plötzlich nicht mehr die Gamerfresse gucken musst, sondern Musik hören kannst.
Ja, und insbesondere sieht dein eigener Internet-Service-Provider auch nicht, was du machst. So, Linus, bist du noch da? Ja. Ich wollte mich von dir verabschieden. Vielen Dank. Nibbler, auch vielen Dank. Und Erdgeist.
Darf ich noch bleiben?
Na gut. Musst du mit Henrik Schröder absprechen, der hier gleich den Night Flight macht mit Punk-Musik. Das war's für heute. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Ich hoffe, ihr habt ein bisschen etwas mitnehmen können. Es wird noch Show Notes geben, wo ihr die Links klicken könnt. Den Podcast zur Sendung gibt es auf fritz.de, später dann auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.